mais bien cher aux abonnés pardonnez-moi
car j'ai péché
et comme un trou j'ai pas trouvé mieux
alors voici la saison de
retour officiel debunka j'ai pénitence
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour cette première vidéo de la saison 2
de débunka j'ai pénitence
fournée 2023 on va probablement en avoir
pour josk 2048
de CD ben cage mais bref c'est surtout
la pénitence rappelez-vous le grand le
grand message de débunka j'ai pénitence
c'est que c'est pas tellement le
débunkage qui est important c'est la
pénitence l'important c'est que ça fasse
mal l'important c'est qu'on souffre et
aujourd'hui pour souffrir j'ai choisi la
race des géants de Julie couvreur une
autre réalité donc je reviens à Julie
couvreur non pas parce que je m'acharne
mais bel et bien parce que c'est un
sujet que j'aime beaucoup le sujet des
géants enfin j'aime beaucoup de toute
façon de parler c'est un sujet qui me
tient à cœur on va dire parce que on dit
beaucoup beaucoup de choses débiles sur
les géants et on a beaucoup d'idées
reçues aussi sur l'approche que les
scientifiques ont de la question de
l'existence des géants ou pas et
justement on va en parler je voulais
j'avais envie d'en reparler alors
peut-être que ce sera pas aussi
pénitence que ça au final puisque j'en
avais un petit peu envie mais voilà ça a
rien à voir avec Julie couvreur la seule
la seule chose c'est que je lui couvrais
à la une énorme audience donc cette
vidéo elle a fait beaucoup beaucoup de
vues et rappelez-vous c'est
c'est une condition sine qua non à un
des Bunka j'ai pénitence que la que le
contenu sur lequel on s'arrête effet
beaucoup de vues là vous avez 200000
vues plus de 200000 vues sur cette vidéo
donc bon il y a pas il y a pas de risque
que mon debunka je fasse plus de vu que
ça et surtout et surtout
c'est elle qui a fait la dernière vidéo
sur le sujet voilà en tout cas ma
connaissance il y a pas de vidéo plus
récente sur le sujet des géants que
celle de Julie couvreur alors hélas je
vais devoir flouter la vidéo parce que
c'est un contenu copyrighté c'est un
documentaire qui vient de la chaîne Gaïa
dont je suppose qu'elle a traduit le les
commentaires donc va falloir que je
floute je défoutrai l'image uniquement
quand je commenterai directement ce qui
se passe à l'image mais à mon avis le
gros le gros du n'importe quoi va se
trouver plutôt dans dans les dans le
texte que dans le que dans le que dans
les images à quoi je m'attends dans un
dans un documentaire comme ça bah au
grand classique j'ai envie de dire de la
de la gigantesologie d'Internet à savoir
des photomontages vraiment pas de grande
qualité
des empilements de cailloux qui sont
tellement trop gros qu'ils ont pu être
fait que par des géants vous apprécierez
la logique
évidemment une personne toute seule ne
peut pas soulever un gros caillou juste
par son ingéniosité nous verrons cela du
mois si le si le si cet argument est
abordé et évidemment les sacro-sainte
références à la Bible évidemment on va
avoir des références à la Bible parce
que sinon il y a aucun intérêt quelle
est l'intérêt de démontrer qu'il y a eu
des géants par le passé si ce n'est de
démontrer que les Écritures saintes sont
réelles parce que c'est ça qui est
derrière le mythe des géants c'est pas
c'est pas d'essayer de de trouver un
accès à la vérité et c'est d'arriver à
démontrer que les récits bibliques et
autres récits des religions monothéistes
sont vraies et véritables parce que les
les saints et autres et autres prophètes
présentés dans la Bible sont censés
avoir vécu à des âges canoniques ce que
les apologies ont interprété comme étant
le signe qu'ils étaient gigantesques
allez savoir pourquoi mais n'empêche que
c'est comme ça que historiquement ça
s'est passé et que du coup aujourd'hui
et bien tous les gens qui défendent
l'existence de la race des géants
défendent implicitement l'idée que une
interprétation littérale ou en tout cas
apologie de la Bible de la Bible et des
autres récits sacrés qui s'en sont
inspirés évidemment
donc ça c'est les trois grands trucs
auxquels je m'attends je m'attends aussi
un petit peu beaucoup à du racisme parce
que généralement il y a toujours de
toute façon dès qu'on dès qu'on va
parler évidemment de bouger des gros
cailloux c'est possible que si on est
des géants bah ça des facto en fait ça
invalide par exemple que les Égyptiens
ont construit leur propre pyramide vous
comprenez les Égyptiens c'était des
êtres humains de taille normale et je le
rappelle ils étaient trop teubés pour
empiler des cailloux des cailloux en
triangle donc on peut pas empiler des
cailloux en triangle quand on est une
civilisation primitive comme les
Égyptiens vous comprenez bien donc on
s'attend évidemment si si empiler des
gros cailloux n'est pas possible quand
on est une civilisation primitive alors
évidemment
évidemment on va toucher un petit peu à
ce petit post colonialisme moi mandats
dans sa vidéo sur le documentaire
Netflix
documentaire Netflix car mon avis je
n'aborderai pas parce que de toute façon
même pour un des bunks et pénitence je
veux dire c'est déjà j'ai pas envie de
payer Netflix et de deux oui je suis
radin et de deux de toute façon il en a
des il a déjà fait un très très bon
boulot je veux dire à partir du moment
où il y a un mec qui se pointe à Malte
pour déclarer ouvertement que toute
l'archéologie qui a été effectuée à
Malte et fosse d'ailleurs le mec il est
quand même il est quand même un niveau
d'arrogance qui est hors du commun je
parle pas de mandat que ça je parle du
mec qui a fait le documentaire Netflix
il faut quand même être un niveau
d'arrogance assez assez hallucinant
Malte c'est quand même en Méditerranée
c'est une île qui était connue des Grecs
et les Grecs enfin les Grecs anciens et
les Grecs anciens c'est eux qui ont
inventé l'archéologie
en tout cas l'archéologie il y a une
continuité historique entre
l'archéologie pratiquée par les Grecs
notamment hérodotes et la l'archéologie
qui est pratiquée aujourd'hui il y a une
vraie continuité historique donc notre
archéologie à nous est directement et
hérité de celle des Grecs faut quand
même avoir des couilles en acier trempé
pour se tenir dessus et clamer haut et
fort 2000 ans d'archéologie je vous
emmerde
faut que je veux dire l'arrogance de ce
gars est juste extraordinaire quoi et il
est tout seul c'est-à-dire il clame
avoir raison contre tous
contre 2000 ans d'archéologie il faut
vraiment faut 2000 ans d'experts 2000
ans de gens qui ont même il y a même des
gens qui ont vu les choses se enfin bon
voilà donc je ne parlerai pas du
documentaire Netflix on va s'arrêter
juste sur les géants aujourd'hui parce
que c'est un sujet que j'aime bien et la
dernière chose à laquelle je m'attends
c'est évidemment des preuves qui ont
disparu comme par hasard
et oui parce que à chaque fois on a le
droit au couplet ah on a découvert un
géant mais son corps a disparu comme par
hasard mais oui mais
qui est-ce que ça sert ça est-ce que ça
sert les scientifiques qui du coup n'ont
pas de preuves sur lesquels travailler
ou est-ce que ça sert aux gens qui
prétend qu'il y a eu des géants mais
comme par hasard les preuves vont
disparu donc vous pouvez pas montrer que
j'ai tort hein à votre avis c'est à qui
c'est qui que ça avantage le plus la
disparition de ses preuves hein bon on
va on va découvrir que toutes les
preuves n'ont pas disparu aujourd'hui je
vais rappeler que l'épreuve que les
preuves des géants n'ont pas toutes
disparu
et que quand on revient dessus sur ses
preuves quand on va les voir quand on
prend le temps de les examiner quand on
prend le temps d'y réfléchir un petit
peu mais en fait on se rend compte que
c'est preuve d'existence des géants sont
généralement des fossiles de mammouth
voilà ou d'autres choses mais en tout
cas elles ont toujours été toutes les
preuves qu'on a encore aujourd'hui des
géants qui enfin des choses qui ont été
interprétées par le passé comme étant
des ossements de géants ou des traces
d'existence de géant ont été
réinterprétés comme étant autre chose et
vous allez voir que ce n'est pas une
interprétation déraisonnable je juste
vous montrer un petit exemple et puis au
passage vous montrer cette vidéo donc
j'avais fait déjà il y a 8 ans et qui
reste redoutablement d'actualité mais je
l'avais fait il y a 8 ans et voilà des
preuves de géants comme ça ça c'est une
dent qui a été découverte en Autriche en
1645 et qui a été interprété comme
appartenant à un être humain géant
et c'est à l'évidence une dent de
mammouth et il y a pas du tout besoin
d'être un expert en anatomie pour s'en
rendre compte puisque il suffit de la
comparer une dent humaine parce que j'ai
fait là vous voyez vous avez les dents
humaines bon évidemment il y a la barre
qui se fout par dessus mais si vous
comparez cette dans la à une danse
humaine oui voilà point d'interrogation
tu de ouf vous vous êtes imaginé que ça
c'était une dent humaine géante
voilà donc il y a même pas besoin d'être
anatomiste si vous voulez pour arriver à
cette conclusion que à partir du moment
où si vous avez des restes de géants
vous pouvez les prendre les comparer des
ossements humains ou à des dents
humaines dans ce cas là et immédiatement
voir que ça n'a rien à voir en fait
donc on peut des banquets très
facilement que ces géants là dont on a
encore les restes ne sont pas des
humains géants ce sont juste d'autres
animaux et après si vous êtes un petit
peu un petit peu versé dans l'anatomie
comparée vous vous rendez rapidement
compte que cette dans la ressemble
redoutablement à une dent d'éléphant et
en l'occurrence à une dent de mammouth
mais il y a pas besoin d'être versé dans
l'anatomie comparée pour se rendre
compte que c'est pas de l'être humain en
tout cas donc ça c'est arrivé
historiquement plein de fois on va le
voir aujourd'hui
pourquoi d'ailleurs on peut maintenant
dire pourquoi est-ce que le consensus
scientifique ne considère pas
l'existence des géants comme une
plausibilité et bien parce que le parce
que tout simplement bah d'une on a des
preuves évidentes de l'évolution humaine
voici une une de mes nombreuses vidéos
sur l'évolution humaine on a des preuves
fossiles de l'évolution humaine et comme
vous pouvez le voir les géants n'y ont
pas leur place le plus gros crâne que
vous voyez ici c'est un gorille et le
reste voilà tous ces humains là enfin en
tout cas toute cette lignée humaine si
je puis m'exprimer ainsi toute cette
ligne est humaine ne comprend aucun
crâne de géant il y a rien eu de plus
gros qu'un gorille dans la lignée
humaine et on le sait très bien parce
qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup de fossiles
des milliers de fossiles arrêtez de dire
il y a trois squelettes qui se battent
en duel il des milliers de fossiles donc
premièrement les géants n'ont pas leur
place dans l'histoire de l'évolution
humaine pour une simple et bonne raison
il y en a pas il y a pas de géants il y
a plein de fossiles mais il y a pas de
géants dans le tas deuxième raison si un
être humain devait être géant il serait
adapté à son gigantisme c'est à dire
qu'un être humain géant ne serait pas
une version agrandie d'un être humain
normal de la même façon qu'un être
humain adulte n'est pas une version
agrandie d'un bébé
ABB si vous le mettez à taille humaine
normale il aurait une tête gigantesque
et des tout petit main et un tout un
gros corps et des tout petits bras et
des toutes petites jambes
un être humain adulte n'est pas une
version agrandie d'un être humain bébé
et de la même manière un être humain
géant ne serait pas une version agrandie
d'un être humain normal donc un être
humain géant ne ressemblerait pas à un
être humain pour vous donner quelques
exemples les jambes les jambes d'un être
humain géant devrait supporter son poids
de géant et pour cela elle ressemblerait
à des jambes de géants à savoir des
jambes d'éléphants d'éléphants de
rhinocéros d'hippopotame c'est-à-dire
des grosses jambes très épaisses
cylindrique avec un pied qui dépasse à
peine en fait de de du diamètre du
cylindre que forme la jambe donc en fait
comme un éléphant vous auriez le pied
directement en dessous du de la jambe il
y aurait rien qui dépasserait parce que
ça risquerait trop facilement de casser
en réalité et pourquoi vous auriez ces
de jambes en forme de colonne tout
simplement parce que la résistance d'un
os et là c'est de la physique pure c'est
pas de la théorie ce que je vous donne
c'est pas un truc que j'invente c'est de
la physique pure et simple la résistance
physique d'un os augmente avec sa
circonférence donc il faudrait des
jambes d'une circonférence
extraordinaire pour qu'on supporter le
poids d'un humain en plus un humain
c'est bipède donc tout son poids ne
tient que sur deux jambes donc si vous
imaginez un humain de la taille d'un
rhinocéros ou d'un éléphant ils ont déjà
des jambes en forme de colonne alors
qu'ils sont quadrupède imaginez
maintenant le diamètre que devrait
atteindre
le enfin la circonférence que devrait
atteindre la jambe d'un humain pour
supporter son poids de bipède sur des
sur son poids sur une posture bipède ce
serait des juste des deux gros piliers
en dessous de vos en dessous de votre
bassin donc ça déjà ça serait très
différent ensuite il y a la structure du
tronc le tronc du corps donc votre torse
et votre abdomen au lieu d'avoir cette
structure en rectangle
ou bien une structure en V si vous êtes
très musclé vous auriez une structure en
V inversée donc une structure conique ou
pyramidale
et ce à des fins de rabaisser le plus
possible votre centre de gravité parce
que quand vous êtes géant vous avez
besoin d'avoir un centre de gravité
extrêmement bas pour être stable plus
votre centre de gravité est bas et plus
vous êtes plus il est près du sol en
fait et plus vous êtes stable pourquoi
c'est important parce que quand vous
êtes géant vous êtes fragile
un animal de grande taille est
proportionnellement plus fragile qu'un
animal de petite taille vous pouvez
lâcher une souris de deux étages de haut
si elle atterrit dans l'herbe elle
partira en courant si vous lâchez un
éléphant de deux étages dehors même en
atterrissant dans une piscine il se
relèvera probablement pas
parce que quand vous êtes gros vous êtes
moins résistant votre poids est une
contrainte c'est une énorme contrainte
vous avez vécu ça vous-même puisqu'en
étant enfant vous pouvez vous prendre
des gamelles absolument épiques dans les
escaliers sans rien vous casser
on l'a tous fait prendre une gamelle
absolument dantesque dans les escaliers
aujourd'hui maintenant que vous êtes un
adulte complètement complètement formé
et de toute votre taille et que votre
centre de gravité est très loin si vous
vous pétez la gueule ne serait-ce que du
trottoir le simple fait d'atterrir sur
vos poignets vous allez vous péter vous
vous risquez de vous péter les poignets
vous allez pas vous les péter je vous le
souhaite pas mais vous risquez de vous
péter les poignets alors que vous pétez
la gueule dans les escaliers quand vous
étiez égoss c'était pas un problème
parce que quand on est plus petit on est
plus résistant on est
proportionnellement plus résistant
donc le tronc d'un être humain géant ne
serait pas un tronc en rectangle il
serait un tronc en V pour rabaisser le
plus possible le centre de gravité et la
tête de votre image géant ne serait pas
une tête humaine bien bien développée
bien formé ce serait une toute petite
tête par rapport au corps parce que pour
la même raison qu'un adulte humain a une
tête plus petite proportionnellement
qu'un bébé humain un bébé humain a une
grosse tête proportionnellement au corps
par rapport à un adulte et ça c'est une
règle universelle dans le monde animal
plus on est gros plus la tête est
proportionnellement petite
à moins que vous ayez un appareil
masticateur sur développer comme un
tyrannosaure par exemple mais la boîte
crânienne quoi qu'il arrive est réduite
et le crâne du Mas c'est essentiellement
de la boîte crânienne très très peu
d'appareils masticateurs ça fait partie
des constantes de l'évolution humaine
notre appareil masticateur c'est réduit
au fur et à mesure de notre évolution
nous avons perdu ce qu'on appelle le
probiatisme donc notre tête notre crâne
est essentiellement de la boîte
crânienne et la boîte crânienne c'est
une constante chez tous les animaux chez
tous les vertébrés la boîte crânienne
devient plus petite proportionnellement
à la taille du corps chez les gros
animaux donc ça on s'attend à scan être
humain ça ait une petite tête un tronc
en cône et des énormes piliers en guise
de jambes on s'attend à ce qu'un être
humain géant ressemble à Godzilla
Godzilla c'est typiquement l'être humain
géant c'est à ça qu'il ressemblerait et
après vous allez évidemment me poser la
question des bras les bras à quoi il
ressemblerait bah là vous avez deux cas
de figure contrairement à Godzilla qui
peut se servir de sa longue queue comme
trépied l'être humain n'a pas de queue
qui lui permet de du coup d'avoir une
sorte de troisième pied pour soutenir le
poids de son corps donc peut-être que
les bras s'allongeraient pour toucher le
sol et dans ce cas là on aurait une
sorte d'êtres humains qui ressemblerait
à un gorille géant imberbe
soit à l'inverse les bras se réduiraient
drastiquement
toujours dans cette optique de vouloir
abaisser le centre de gravité parce
qu'en ayant des bras géants attachés à
vos épaules
bah en fait vous fait vous déplacez le
centre de gravité vers le haut donc soit
il vous faut des très longs bras et dans
ce cas là vous vous réadapter une
posture quadrupède le gorille géant
imberbe soit vous réduisez la taille des
bras et dans ce cas là le centre de
gravité va se redéplace vers le bas
puisque du coup les bras ne n’attirent
plus en fait le centre de gravité vers
le poids des bras attaché aux épaules
n'attire plus le centre de gravité vers
le haut donc ça c'est c'est à ça que
devrait ressembler un être humain donc
c'est un peu ce qu'on voit chez
tyrannosaure par exemple le poids le
poids des bras est soustrait au poids de
l'avant du corps ce qui fait que le
centre de gravité se est préservé enfin
le position du centre de gravité au
niveau du bassin est préservé ou en tout
cas plus proche du bassin qui est
vraiment le point de stabilité du
tyrannosaure
donc voilà pour la deuxième raison pour
laquelle donc on ne s'attend pas à
trouver des géants le consensus
scientifique prévoit qu'il n'y ait pas
de du main géant c'est que de toute
façon un humain géant ça ne
ressemblerait pas à un être humain géant
et si un humain géant devait exister il
ressemblerait à Godzilla ou à gorille
géant imberbe mais en tout cas il
ressemblerait pas un être humain donc ça
c'est et ça je pense c'est l'argument le
plus béton parce que c'est que de la
physique ce que je viens de vous dire là
c'est c'est pas un oui en théorie ça
ressemblerait pas non c'est que de la
physique il ne peut pas en être
autrement c'est de la physique de la
biophysique pure élémentaire et
élémentaire c'est surtout ça c'est même
pas compliqué ce que je viens de vous
dire et enfin la troisième raison bah
c'est comme je vous l'ai expliqué plutôt
des
êtres humains géants et il y en a qui
ont été identifiés dans le registre
fossile et pour ceux pour lesquels des
preuves ont été conservées jusqu'à nos
jours et il y en a et il y en a beaucoup
nous le verrons pour ceux dont les
preuves ont été réservé jusqu'à nos
jours c'est être humain géants ont
toujours toujours toujours
systématiquement été réidentifié comme
étant en fait c'était quelque chose
d'autre généralement des ossements de
mammouth ou des dents de mammouth et
parfois c'était même pas compliqué de le
faire notamment par exemple avec le la
fameuse dents de crème d'Autriche qui
était définitivement celle d'un mammouth
qui était définitivement pas celle d'un
être humain en tout cas qui était
définitivement celle d'un mammouth donc
voici toutes les raisons pour lesquelles
la science ne croit pas en l'existence
des géants c'est pas une croyance ça
découle de trois faisceaux de preuves
principaux l'absence de fossiles
le fait que l'épreuve ont été
ré-identifiées plus tard comme étant des
choses tout à fait banales et le fait
que du coup en théorie de toute façon ça
ne marche pas voilà théoriquement la
physique ne prévoit pas qu'un être
humain géant puisse exister de toute
façon ou si il existait il ne ressemble
il ne serait absolument pas identifiable
comme étant un être humain géant
commençons du coup cette vidéo alors le
titre c'est hybride humain et géant
donc là là je sens comme qui dirait
qu'on va nous un truc ouais une c'est un
truc que j'avais oublié c'est je sens
qu'on va comme qui dirait nous montrer
des gens qui sont grands vous savez des
êtres humains grands comme Robert Ludo
Robert Dulot qui est d'ailleurs
l'illustration parfaite de ce que je
vous disais sur pourquoi un être humain
ne devrait pas un être humain ne peut
pas être juste une version agrandi d'un
être humain géant ne peut pas être juste
une version agrandie d'un être humain
normal c'est que Robert ludelot c'était
définitivement une version agrandie d'un
être humain normal et qui arrivait à 2
mètres 32 il tenait plus de bout
parce que ces jambes sont pas assez
épaisses tout simplement parce que son
centre de gravité était trop haut il
avait besoin d'une canne à Robert Wadlow
pardon c'est Robert Wadlow
qui avait de fait atteint ah non 2
mètres 72 il avait atteint les deux
mètres 72 c'est écrit là donc Robert
Wadlow pas de Ludo a atteint les deux
mètres 72 et donc il était il tenait pas
vraiment debout il avait besoin d'une
canne parce que c'est trop de mètres 72
donc ça c'est l'illustration parfaite
donc là je sens qu'on va nous montrer
juste des êtres humains qui sont grands
mais qui sont définitivement des Homo
sapiens et qui aussi loin qu'on puisse
tracer leur généalogie
était humain mais bon on va dire que
c'était des hybrides humains géants
parce que parce que parce que
donc il faut bien voir qu'un être humain
un être humain de grande taille donc par
exemple je vais vous prendre alors
je tape toast NBA player donc le plus
grand basketteur de la NBA
qui mesure alors évidemment c'est en
pied de mettre 31 à 2 mètres 31 un être
humain Homo sapiens est un athlète donc
vous pouvez partir on va partir sur le
principe
on anticipant les arguments qui vont
être présentés là on va partir sur le
principe que jusqu'à 2 mètres 31 du coup
pas 32 jusqu'à 2m31 vous pouvez encore
être homo sapiens et être un athlète et
jusqu'à 2 mètres 72
vous êtes toujours Homo sapiens mais ça
devient compliqué de vivre et en
l'occurrence il est mort très très jeune
ça devient très compliqué de vivre mais
en gros tant que vous êtes en dessous de
2 mètres 31 vous ne peut pas faire
l'hypothèse raisonnable que vous êtes
autre chose que un 100% Homo sapiens
parce que il y a des joueurs NBA qui
font de mettre 31 comme on l'a pu le
voir et qui ont et qui sont en parfaite
santé qui sont des athlètes donc on est
un homo sapiens tout à fait normal quand
on fait 2m31 au moins et ensuite on est
homo sapiens pathologique jusqu'à 2
mètres 72
et au dessus de 2m72 là on pourra
commencer à éventuellement faire
l'hypothèse pas trop dégueulasse qu'on
est peut-être pas sur de l'homo sapiens
et là on va pouvoir commencer à discuter
mais tout ce qui est en dessous de 2
mètres 72 je prends pas
vas-y envoie-nous la race des géants
les yeux de cette espèce de géant dont
les os remplissent les collines
américaines ont admiré les chutes du
Niagara comme le font les nôtres Abraham
Lincoln Abraham Lincoln qui est
évidemment un grand scientifique dans
l'âme je le rappelle
la fin de l'été 1908 près des chaos qui
amons à Collins ville dans l'Illinois
des ouvriers du bâtiment ont
accidentellement mis au jour une tombe
en pierre qui contenait plusieurs corps
de géants mesurant chacun puis de 2
mètres de haut
vous noterez l'absence totale de barre
d'échelle sur cette photo
vous noterez l'absence de d'un
quelconque squelette sur cette photo
mystère autour d'une grande espèce
d'humain donc encore une fois vous
noterez l'absence totale d'une
quelconque forme d'échelle sur cette
photo qui vous permettrait de dire ah
oui c'est vachement grand
une race de géant qui aurait autrefois
habité l'Amérique je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que ça allait sentir le racisme
vous le sentez venir le racisme
antinatif américain là les natifs
américains c'était des hybrides entre
une race de géants primitifs et des Homo
sapiens vous vous le sentez là comme on
va déshumaniser les natifs américains là
c'est ça qui m'énerve en fait avec ces
théories c'est que c'est impossible de
tenir ce discours sans d'une part
insulter les scientifiques de menteur ou
de malhonnête ou de débiles et d'autre
part c'est impossible de prétendre qu'il
y a eu une race éteinte ou une
civilisation est un grandiose dont il ne
reste aucune trace évidemment c'est
impossible de prétendre ça sans au
passage écorché les civilisations qui
elle était réellement là
c'est impossible de tenir ce discours
sans écorcher les civilisations qui
elles étaient réellement là parce que
vous allez devoir forcer vous allez
devoir trouver des preuves aux forcing
vous allez devoir forcer la trouvaille
de preuve et donc vous allez faire quoi
vous allez les chercher dans le vrai
registre archéologique c'est par exemple
les pyramides vous voulez prétendre
qu'il y a une race d'Atlante qui a vécu
et bien vous allez faire quoi vous allez
chercher en Egypte et vous allez dire
bah regardez c'est eux qui ont construit
les pyramides en se faisant vous prenez
les pyramides vous les enlevez du
registre archéologique des vrais
égyptiens pour le maître dans le
registre de votre Atlantide pourri et ce
faisant vous daignez aux Égyptiens
le droit d'avoir construit les pyramides
d'avoir accompli des choses grandioses
c'est un exemple les pyramides c'est que
un exemple mais vous ne pouvez pas en
fait
soustraire au registre archéologique
d'autres civilisations sans écorcher la
mémoire de ces civilisations
si c'est civilisations sont éteintes ce
qui n'est même pas le cas des [ __ ]
d'Indiens d'Amérique c'est à dire que là
on va vous expliquer que les Indiens
d'Amérique sont une race de géants où
sont descendants d'une race de géants au
moins en partie alors que on a des
Indiens d'Amérique aujourd'hui ils sont
toujours vivants ils sont toujours pas
géants on a fait des analyses ADN il y a
aucune trace de gigantisme dans leur ADN
alors pourquoi par Belzébuth
[Rires]
le racisme on ne peut pas tenir ses
théories là sans être raciste c'est
impossible vous allez devoir appliquer à
un moment ou un autre du racisme
désolé si vous êtes intenante c'est
théories non en fait je suis pas désolé
vous aviez qu'à pas être raciste
en triangle
avec une population comprise entre 25
000 et 50000 habitants en l'an 1000 donc
des grandes civilisations
à propos de ceux qu'ils appelaient les
voyez cette cette grande civilisation
qui a construit des villes qui a
construit des monuments vous sentez
encore une fois comment on va expliquer
qu'elles avaient atteint un stade de
civilisation avancée c'est dégueulasse
ce que je viens de dire mais c'est
exactement ça qu'ils disent vous vous
sentez comme on va nous expliquer que
ils ont atteint un stade de civilisation
avancée uniquement parce qu'ils sont les
descendants d'une race supérieure
et oui je viens de dire race supérieure
parce que c'est exactement ça qu'on va
vous dire
je l'ai pas vu le dos je l'ai pas vu ce
truc mais je les connais par cœur leurs
arguments
pourrait-il être lié au grand corps
découvert accidentellement dans la tombe
antique et ni possible que ce surco avec
son tombé soit les restes d'une grande
civilisation qui n'a pas seulement
parcouru l'Amérique mais aussi le monde
l'hypothèse l'hypothèse sortie du cul de
nulle part
on vient de nous dire le chercheur
bradolsen le documentaire nous dit
auteur ah bah c'est pas pareil
pas pareil le monsieur il écrit il écrit
c'est ce qu'il fait j'ai même pas besoin
d'aller c'est ça qui est marrant c'est
que j'ai même pas besoin d'aller
vérifier l'information comme quoi il
serait effectivement chercheur le
documentaire lui-même me dit non il est
pas chercheur
donc c'est pire qu'un expert en mousse
c'est à pas expert du tout enfin c'est
juste un expert autoproclamé
suivant c'est la différence entre un
consensus scientifique et un expert
autoproclamé vous voyez un consensus
scientifique ce sont les autres
scientifiques qui vous déclarent expert
c'est à dire que tous les experts se
disent experts mutuellement confirme
leur expertise mutuellement c'est à dire
que vous avez plus d'une opinion qui
vous déclare expert alors qu'un expert
autoproclamé il y a que sa seule
expertise à lui qui lui permet de se
déclarer expert c'est c'est un cercle un
seul c'est un cercle mais en fait c'est
un boomerang quoi c'est à dire voilà mon
expertise ah bah c'est moi c'est moi
pareil l'arrogance
l'arrogance de cette position on me
déclare on me dit tout le temps que je
suis arrogant mais imaginez l'arrogance
qu'il faut avoir pour s'autoproclamer
expert
les scientifiques ils sont pas arrogants
parce que c'est les autres scientifiques
qui confirment leur expertise
c'est les autres scientifiques qui
disent aux scientifiques oui toi je
reconnais ton expertise et plus vous
avez d'autres scientifiques qui sont
eux-mêmes experts et déclarés experts
pour d'autres scientifiques qui
confirment votre expertise plus vous
êtes un expert
reconnu en tout cas mais si vous êtes
tout seul à reconnaître si vous êtes le
seul expert à reconnaître votre propre
expertise
vous avez fortes chances d'être un
charlot hier
c'est bien de le reconnaître
qui est ensuite devenu la culture
puis la culture mississippiienne qui
englobait
toutes il existe plus de 2000 tumulus
pyramidaux en Amérique du Nord
y compris au Mexique
pour l'instant tout ce qu'on vous a dit
c'est il y a plusieurs cultures et
plusieurs tumulus
hauteur de compodium of de émeraude
tablette pareil un expert autoproclamé
d'autres créatures diverses certains
sont de simplementicules ce qui est
intéressant c'est que des dolmens ont
également été
les gros cailloux si c'est des
rocaillots il y a que des gros monsieur
qui ont pu qui ont pu bouger des gros
cailloux
attendez ça va venir
c'est encore pire que ce que j'imaginais
c'est à dire moi je viens de dire un
argument qui est s'il y a des rocaillous
s'il y avait des gros cailloux empilés
c'est qu'il a fallu un gros monsieur
pour leur payer les rocaillous
maintenant c'est encore pire on te dit
s'il y a une grande tombe c'est qu'il y
a un géant enterré dessous
alors ça
c'est quelqu'un qui a même pas je sais
pas moi c'est vous vous êtes jamais allé
à Rome au tumulus au château Saint-Ange
qui est en fait un tumulus qui est en
fait une tombe d'empereur Romains
le château Saint-Ange du coup alors
c'est le débunker le plus nul que j'ai
jamais fait et pourtant j'en ai fait des
débunks nuls le château Saint-Ange c'est
donc un château entier une fortification
qui a été construit sur le tumulus d'un
empereur romain
d'un seul empereur romain pas de pas de
36 il y a un seul empereur romain
enterré sur cet énorme tumulus et ça
qu'on ça suffit à construire à faire la
place pour construire un château donc il
a été construit pour l'empereur Adrien
en 135 après Jésus-Christ dis donc
c'était l'empereur Adrien il devait être
vachement grand bah non il était pas
vachement grand l'empereur Adrien on le
sait parce qu'on a des écrits qui disent
que c'était un être humain tout à fait
normal
donc ouais là je m'attendais pas en fait
je suis désespéré parce que je
m'attendais vraiment pas à l'argument
une grosse tombe c'est forcément pour un
grand monsieur
ça je
c'est vrai qu'on a jamais construit de
grands tumulus pour des petits monsieur
jamais
à une heure d'avion de Paris une heure
d'avion de Paris
que vous le trouverez le château
Saint-Ange
particulièrement difficile ce qui les
relie et le fait qu'il s'agisse de
grands monuments érigés à la mémoire de
personnes dont la vie était très
spirituelle dans un passé lointain ouais
puis ça on n'a jamais vu ça construire
des grands monuments on n'a jamais vu
même en Europe je veux dire construire
des grands monuments à la mémoire de
personnages importants à ne se fait pas
voyons faut absolument être une race de
géants extraterrestre pour y arriver
plus de 15
00 encore une fois j'adore c'est
regardez en Géorgie dans les dans les
dunes de sable de Géorgie la preuve
d'une race de géant on vous montre un
monsieur ici on vous montre le squelette
ici je vous invite à quand même à
regarder la taille de la tête du
monsieur la taille de la tête de ce
squelette
est d'essayer de vous convaincre
vous-même que ce squelette là c'est un
squelette de géant
les mecs ils ont pas honte ils ont pas
honte c'est écrit une race de géants et
on vous montre un squelette de taille
normal
on vous dit les archéologues viennent de
faire la découverte mystifiante de
squelette d'être humain qui était
haut de cette pièce
haut de cette pieds
in meeters
cette pied en mètres ça fait 2 mètres 13
c'est fou comme si le mot géant avait
été utilisé abusivement pour désigner un
être humain très très grand
alors ouais on va me rétorquer mais
peut-être que les Indiens ils étaient
tout petits et que du coup c'est cette
pièce c'était très grand oui mais on
reste dans la gamme de la variabilité
humaine je vous rappelle que notre
hypothèse de base c'est que jusqu'à 2
mètres 31 un être humain Homo sapiens
100% est en bonne santé
on efface à un être humain qui est dans
la gamme de variation des êtres humains
en bonne santé on est même pas dans la
gamme des êtres humains pathologiques
voilà et on vous montre cette coupure de
presse tapageuse en essayant de vous
faire croire que ça c'est une preuve qui
a des géants qui ont existé
on est à quel niveau de foutage de
gueule à votre avis là faisons une
échelle de 0 à 10 est-ce qu'on aurait
pas atteint 12 déjà hein 4 minutes 19 je
pourrais m'arrêter là je veux dire on
vous ment ce documentaire vous ment déjà
à 4 minutes 19
on n'a pas encore eu le racisme
je le sens venir toujours on n'a pas
encore eu le racisme mais déjà ce
documentaire à 4 minutes 19 vous ment on
va voir à combien il atteint le racisme
le point Godwin
j'ai répertorié plus de 1500 articles de
journaux
encore un article de journal qui nous
dit qu'on a trouvé 15 à 20 squelettes et
on nous donne pas la taille si seven
feat tall encore une fois 7 pieds de
haut
cette pied de haut j'ai même pas refaire
ma conversion 2 mètres 13
boom encore une coupure de presse faut
voir qu'en fait
Mindy
tall peut-être que ce sera un peu mieux
de mettre 64 ah là on rentre dans la
gamme
légèrement on est juste au dessus de la
taille de Robert Wadlow on en est encore
suffisant on en est encore suffisamment
proche pour dire on est certainement
dans du pathologique de l'humain
pathologique mais en tout cas là au
moins on commence après c'est une
coupure de presse c'est pas un article
pire review et il y a pas de photo pour
confirmer mais au moins là on peut
commencer à parler d'un être humain
anormalement grand
de là aller chercher les extraterrestres
pour 2 cm de trop c'est pas non plus la
fête du slip mais au moins on commence à
nous parler d'un être humain normalement
grand et c'est certainement un vilain
mensonge mais bref
au moins là mais vous vous rendez compte
que ça là c'est coupure de presse qu'on
nous met ce sont des preuves pour eux
qui ont été sélectionnés ça c'est censé
vous convaincre
encore une fois je vous invite à vous
arrêter deux minutes sur l'honnêteté
intellectuelle de gens qui vous mettent
des coupures de presse en espérant que
vous ne les lirez pas et en espérant que
vous ne ferez pas ces conversions
pour aller vous rendre compte vous-même
que 2 mètres soi-même 2 mètres 74 c'est
pas le bout du monde sachant que Robert
Wadlow a atteint les deux mètres 72
c'est pas le bout du monde du tout
c'est pas suffisant pour parler d'une
race de géant
et combien on en a trouvé des squelettes
alorsing Highway phone one sketon ils
ont trouvé un squelette
c'est pas suffisant pour faire une
population ainsi un squelette un
squelette ça peut être un individu
pathologique
de la fin des années 1800 les géants
pots rouges ouh là là
9 squelettes qui étaient ceux d'un
Indien ceux des Indiens et on n'a pas la
taille
donc la seule indication de taille qu'on
a là c'est un avant-bras de 4
pieds de long un avant-bras de 4 pieds
de long ça fait 1m20 donc un bras avant
de 4 pieds ça ferait un bras avant de
1m20 1m22 et la longueur d'un bras
humain classique c'est aux alentours de
d'une soixantaine de centimètres donc là
on aurait éventuellement
quelque chose de géant là on pourrait
avoir quelque chose de géant encore que
dans la longueur du bras mesurer
classiquement on inclut pas la main
alors que là peut-être que la maille
inclue le truc c'est que c'est pas clair
parce que on nous dit fort arme alors
est-ce que ça veut dire l'avant-bras
c'est-à-dire cette partie là est-ce que
ça veut dire le bras avant c'est à dire
tout depuis l'épaule jusqu'au doigt
c'est pas clair mais quoi qu'il arrive
ça manque de photos encore une fois
c'est toujours la même chose c'est les
affirmations extraordinaires demandent
au moins des preuves
je demande même pas des preuves
extraordinaires à ce niveau là ça sert à
rien au moins des preuves quoi
montrez-moi une photo du du bras avec
une barre d'échelle à côté quoi je veux
dire qu'au moins on est une idée de ce
qu'on regarde
à propos de diverses voilà huit pieds de
haut c'est pas non plus extraordinaire
là on est encore sur un géant qui va
faire quoi encore une fois cette pied
donc on nous dit c'est gigantesque bah
non reste dans la gamme de variations
humaines en plus quand on voit toutes
ces coupures de presse on pourrait se
dire mais attends attends attends il y a
pas de fumée sans feu là il y a quand
même beaucoup de il y a quand même
beaucoup de preuves ce serait bien quand
même qu'on ait une idée en général de la
taille de ces Indiens histoire de ces
Indiens d'Amérique ça se trouve les
Indiens d'Amérique étaient effectivement
en moyenne plus grand bah sachez que ça
a été fait ce calcul voilà
publier dans la revue sauce eastern
archéological friends vous avez un
article dont le titre est des
Amérindiens géants fait ou fantaisie
spoiler alerte fantasy
voilà voilà donc il repartent sur
l'origine coloniale extrêmement
coloniale extrêmement raciste de l'idée
que les Indiens d'Amérique seraient une
race différente d'êtres humains et qu'il
serait et que ça se verrait dans leur
taille ils ont fait des statistiques sur
la taille squelettes d'Amérindiens
spoiler alert ils sont pas spécialement
plus grands que nous en moyenne donc
même si les squelettes géants qu'ils ont
été qui ont été retrouvés là étaient
effectivement de cette pied de haut donc
je le rappelle cette pieds de haut ça
fait 2 mètres 10
même s'il faisait 7 pieds de haut comme
le déclare ces journaux assez coupures
de presse à sensation avec toute la
crédibilité qui implique le fait qu'il y
a pas non plus de photos bon bah
c'était des
c'était littéralement pas la moyenne en
fait c'était littéralement pas ça que ça
la taille de la population moyenne
c'était juste des gens qui étaient
exceptionnels en grands et des gens qui
sont exceptionnellement grands on en a
aussi en Europe c'est pas une spécialité
nord-américaine d'être spécialement
grand
encore un expert autoproclamé du
paranormal
dans la plupart de leurs journaux les
chefs de tribus étaient décrits comme
étant des géants
oui bah ça c'était ça ça faisait partie
comme l'explique cet article là puisque
là je crois même qu'on a cette image là
en particulier qui est réutilisé ah non
c'est pas exactement la même mais donc
il l'explique aussi dans cet article là
que c'est une c'est un mythe qui a été
inventé par les par les explorateurs
pour se faire mousser quoi donc ils
avaient peut-être une impression globale
parce que ils étaient spécialement pas
bien nourri les marins j'en sais rien
enfin en tout cas c'est ce qu'ils disent
dans l'article ils disent peut-être que
les marins eux-mêmes étaient
spécialement pas très bien nourris et
que du coup parce que pour s'engager
pour s'engager comme mousse il fallait
quand même
fallait quand même être sacrément dans
la merde à l'époque c'était pas une
c'était pas une joie de partir en mer à
l'époque donc peut-être que déjà de base
la taille moyenne d'un équipage européen
à costant sur les terres d'Amérique du
Nord étaient pas non plus excessivement
grandes c'était des gens plutôt mal
nourris et en plus il faut rajouter à ça
que revenir avec des comptes et légendes
de trucs extraordinaires ça plaît
toujours plus à votre financier que de
revenir avec des enfin votre mécène que
de revenir avec des histoires de ouais
on a vu des gants ils étaient comme nous
surtout qu'à l'époque il voulait surtout
pas qu'il soit comme et c'est pour ça
que je dis ça tout ça c'est très très
profondément enraciné dans le dans un
racisme colonial c'est c'est d'une c'est
un mode de pensée post-coloniale
complètement
et aussi je vous je m'arrête
complètement sur le fait que encore une
fois il existe des Indiens aujourd'hui
je veux dire les Amérindiens n'ont pas
disparu ils existent encore aujourd'hui
aucun n'est gigantesque
enfin si il y en a probablement qui sont
taille basketteur encore une fois mais
là on nous parle que de d'Indiens qui
sont taille basketteur pour l'instant il
y en a qu'un seul de dans toutes les
coupures de presse qu'on a vu il y en a
qu'un qui est un squelette complet qui a
l'air de faire une taille suffisamment
suffisamment grande pour être qualifiée
de pathologique c'est vrai que j'ai pas
précisé pathologique c'est évidemment
une une
un cas de gigantisme donc de 10 paires
sécrétions de au niveau de la glande
pituitaire donc c'est la glande
pituitaire qui sécrète beaucoup trop
d'hormones de croissance entre autres
problèmes physiologiques et qui du coup
fait que l'individu n'arrête pas de
grandir donc c'est ça c'est le
gigantisme pathologique dont je parle
depuis tout à l'heure quand je parle de
pathologique et donc pour l'instant il y
a qu'un seul finalement article qui nous
a présenté vraiment un truc
extraordinaire à savoir enfin qui nous a
parlé d'un truc extraordinaire sans nous
le montrer évidemment qui est
l'avant-bras ou le bras entier qui fait
deux fois la taille de ce qui devrait
faire donc ça c'était à peu près la
seule le seul la seule petite coupure de
presse qu'ils ont réussi à sélectionner
qui était réellement
qui présentait réellement quelque chose
d'extraordinairement grand c'était
celle-là
c'est pas énorme et puis bah ça c'est
une gravure qui a été faite certainement
pas de première main je veux dire
évidemment que le mec était pas là en
train de graver pendant la rencontre tu
sais évidemment que ça lui a été raconté
évidemment que ça lui a été raconté donc
évidemment qu'il va pas graver autre
chose que ce qu'on lui raconte le mec
qui a fait cette gravure là donc il faut
bien remettre les choses à leur place on
est sur du racisme colonial à l'époque
on veut faire croire que les on veut
dire au monde que les Indiens sont
différents d'une part parce qu'on a
envie de se présenter comme des
aventuriers d'autre part parce qu'on a
envie de de plaire à la galerie de
d'autre part parce que on veut
convaincre le monde que les Indiens sont
pas comme nous hein enfin que les
Amérindiens sont pas comme nous bref
les racines racistes racines racistes
qui
exalte leur parfum nauséabond jusqu'à
aujourd'hui puisque vous ne verrez pas
d'Indiens s'exprimer dans cette vidéo
je l'ai pas vu la vidéo mais je le sais
je le sais que les Indiens d'Amérique
modernes ne défendent pas ses théories
puisqu'evidemment elle pue le racisme
je le sais et vous ne verrez pas de chef
indien ou de représentants de des
Indiens et s'il y en a un je te jure
il y a un bouquin là
j'en mord une page j'en mange une page
voilà j'arrache une page et je la mange
si on voit un chef si on voit un indien
s'exprimer dans cette vidéo positivement
évidemment
en faveur de l'hypothèse de la race des
géants c'est vous dire à quel point je
suis convaincu que ça pue le racisme
faux
faux c'est faux c'est faux c'est faux
parce que les données sont ici je vous
mettrai l'article dans la description
entre cette pratique en Amérique du Nord
et le journal de bord que l'on a pu lire
du tout premier bateau qui a débarqué
c'est les mêmes théories racistes
d'ailleurs que celles qui ont fait
naître Bigfoot Bigfoot à la base c'est
pas un primate oh là là
donc les gros cailloux les gros géants
c'est les mêmes théories racistes
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant de le noter
qui ont fait naître le mythe de Bigfoot
Bigfoot c'est aujourd'hui on le
représente comme un primate venant de
l'ère glaciaire qui aurait survécu
jusqu'à aujourd'hui la naissance de
Bigfoot c'est en fait une tribu indienne
semi mythique je suis pas sûr si elle
est complètement mythique ou juste semi
mythique qui s'appelle les sasquatch
vous savez comme le sasquat chez one au
Canada donc il s'appelle les sasquats et
cette tribu bah du coup elle est pas
mythique par définition s'ils ont donné
le nom d'un état d'après cette tribu
c'est qu'elle existait donc ça vient
d'une interprétation
erronée et fortement nos éléments
racistes de la tribu des sasquats qui
aurait été des êtres humains
gigantesques et plus et qui ont acquis
au fur et à mesure que leur mythe était
réinterprété que une pilosité excessive
qui leur donnait un aspect beaucoup plus
brut et beaucoup plus primitif encore
plus primitif donc vous voyez
le sasquatch en fait le aujourd'hui le
mythe du sasquatch et le mythe des
géants qu'on nous présente ici des
Indiens d'Amérique géants c'est la même
racine
Bull shitesque à la base c'est une
interprétation selon laquelle ouais
c'est des Indiens ils sont gigantesques
ils ont des grands pieds ils ont des
grands pieds ils laissent des grandes
empreintes de pieds vous rendez pas
compte c'est forcément des c'est
forcément pas des êtres humains alors il
y en a une qui est parti dans la
direction c'est des géants c'est des
géants des mythes anciens ce à quoi
on nous montre des des statuts de l'île
de Pâques je vais revenir là-dessus donc
il y a une direction de cette mythologie
bullshitesque qui a été prise d'un côté
pour dire c'était des géants du passé et
l'autre direction l'autre petit rejeton
de cette théorie bullshitesque ça a été
le mythe du Bigfoot c'est à dire que au
lieu d'en faire une race de géants qui
était donc pas les indiens mais du coup
une race de géants qui a précédé les
Indiens et qui s'est hybridé avec eux et
qui leur a transmis la civilisation puis
évidemment les Indiens ne peut pas avoir
ils ne peuvent pas avoir une
civilisation à eux c'est pas possible
ils sont trop cons pour ça et de l'autre
côté c'est ce sont effectivement les
mais ce sont des Indiens qui étaient si
primitifs que le mythe a évolué de telle
sorte qu'il est carrément devenu un
primate non humain
je vous l'avais dit que ça lui est
mais c'est le même mythe à la base c'est
vous vous rendez compte même mythe à la
base et donc là pour nous prouver que
les Amérindiens étaient
donc des êtres humains géants on nous
montre quoi bah les statues de l'île de
Pâques vous savez celles qui ont été
dressées par les Amérindiens
mais oui bien sûr les statuts de l'île
de Pâques des Amérindiens
les poly les Polynésiens n'ont rien à
voir là dedans
les pauvres pauvres Maui
[Musique]
sérieusement
elle The Rock The Rock et comment il
s'appelle Aquaman
vous dérouiller vous imaginez ouais pour
prouver la théorie ce serait marrant tu
vois que on en arrive là
pour prouver la théorie qui a eu des
géants par le passé vous voyez les
statuts de Lidl Pâques elles ont été
faites par les Polynésiens et vous voyez
les Polynésiens d'aujourd'hui c'est
Aquaman et The Rock vous avez vu comment
ils sont géants
c'est forcément qu'il y avait des géants
et ce serait un meilleur argument je
trouve
du peuple rapanouit et elle superbe
rapanoui qui n'a donc rien à voir avec
les Indiens
et donc c'est la race des géants d'avant
qui supervisait la construction des
parce qu'évidemment les rapanouis ils
étaient trop cons pour faire des statues
dans une centaine d'endroits différents
dans le monde entier c'est merveilleux
c'est merveilleux on a des statuts de
l'île de Pâques absolument partout dans
le monde ah ouais non ah bon bah tant
pis
on retrouve les mêmes types d'exemples
partout ah oui des statues de l'île de
Pâques il y en a partout des statuts de
l'île de Pâques hein tout le monde dans
tout le monde en a fait les chinois ils
en ont fait les Indiens ils en ont fait
enfin les Indiens d'Inde ils en ont fait
ben oui les Africains il y a plein de
statuts de l'île de Pâques en Afrique
d'ailleurs les appels les statues de
Patrick
comment on peut gober un argument comme
ça moi je comprends pas
ouais c'est pour ça que j'y crois pas
d'ailleurs
est ajouté de la crédibilité à ce mythe
a été la découverte à travers le monde
de 100 grandes empreintes mystérieuses
d'apparence humaine conservée dans la
pierre depuis des milliers d'années
très intéressant que vous montriez cette
photo là
parce que ça c'est une empreinte qui est
en Afrique et notamment elle est en
Afrique du Sud et vous savez dans quoi
elle est faite cette empreinte dans du
granite dans du granite du granite
je vous laisse le temps de je vous
laisse le temps de conceptualiser qu'il
existe une empreinte de pas dans du
granite chercher l'erreur
chercher l'erreur bon alors pour ceux
qui ont besoin d'un cours de géologie le
granite c'est une roche c'est une roche
d'origine magmatique donc c'est une
roche qui se forme dans les profondeurs
de la taille
et qui quand elle atteint la surface
quand elle atteint une distance
suffisamment raisonnable de la surface
commence à durcir de telle sorte que
quand elle a atteint la surface elle est
déjà dure
c'est une roche qui est chaude dans les
profondeurs de la terre donc elle n'est
malléable que dans les profondeurs de la
terre et qui en formant un Pluton qui va
se diriger vers la surface va se
refroidir et donc durcir et en
atteignant la surface elle est déjà dure
elle est déjà dure
comme ma planète
elle est déjà dure comment vous faites
une empreinte de pas dans une roche
granitique qui est déjà dur
et surtout quand vous êtes vous-même à
défenseur de cette théorie à de base
comment vous faites pour
ignorer complètement ça parce que
utilisez ça comme un argument à deux
balles c'est une chose le maître dans un
documentaire comme étant une des preuves
les plus extraordinaires de l'existence
des géants s'en est une autre mais se
passer de vérifier qu'il s'agit
réellement d'une véritable empreinte de
pied et pas seulement d'une part et
idolie ou d'un truc qui aurait été
sculpté par un créationniste parce que
ça existe aussi
et il existe aussi des civilisations du
passé qui ont eux-mêmes sculpté des
empreintes de pas parce que les
empreintes de pas ont été sculptés par
exemple par des bushmenes des bushmenes
ils aimaient bien sculpter des
empreintes de pas dans la pierre ça fait
partie des trucs qu'on sait qu'il
faisait puisqu'ils nous l'ont dit
puisqu'il nous le disent encore
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs puisqu'ils
existent encore c'est bouche même donc
comment tu te passes de vérifier cette
information avant de la présenter au
public comme argent comptant et bah faut
être soit un débile soit un arnaqueur
je leur donne le crédit d'être des
arnaqueurs j'ai pas envie de dire qu'ils
sont débiles moi je pense qu'on essaie
de nous arnaquer
et on essaye tellement de nous arnaquer
qu'il y a que quatre doigts dans cette
dans cette empreinte de pas
il y a que quatre orteils et ouais et
ouais ouais alors est-ce que ça veut
dire que toutes ces empreintes de pas
qu'on a vu avant sont toutes faites
mais j'en sais rien
ça ça je veux dire c'est clairement une
pareille d'Oli c'est l'érosion qui a
créé ça très très clairement encore une
fois quatre orteils à moins qu'il avait
le petit orteil opposable le ce géant
on voit même d'ailleurs les figures
d'érosion autour qui sont exactement les
mêmes ça pourquoi il a pas dit que
c'était une vache géante là cette
empreinte à deux doigts c'est juste de
l'appareil idolie de l'érosion sur un
sur un cars
étrange qui pourrait ajouter de la
crédibilité à ce mythe
donc l'empreinte de suivante qu'il nous
présente c'est cette empreinte de pas
elle a absolument pas de vous de
plantaire donc niveau réalisme tu
repasses elle a quand même ces cinq
doigts celle-là au moins celle là au
moins elle a 5 orteils elle a au moins
la décence de post food de nous niveau
nombre d'orteils je vous rappelle encore
une fois que un être humain de cette
taille là c'est pas du tout ce qui nous
ont décrit un être humain de 2 mètres
voire même de 3 mètres de haut ça a pas
des panars aussi grands là on est sur un
être humain qui fait au moins deux fois
cette taille là enfin on est sur un être
humain de 4,5 mètres de haut et arriver
là normalement on devrait avoir comme je
le rappelle des gros pieds cylindriques
donc il y a deux problèmes majeur dans
cette empreinte c'est que d'une cette
empreinte n'est absolument pas une
preuve de l'existence des géants dont
ils nous ont parlé avant qui était de
taille raisonnablement humaine même
s'ils étaient très très grands ça
restait des êtres humains très grands
regardez ça c'est un être humain normal
un être humain très grand il aurait le
pied qui arriverait là tu vois mais il
aurait pas un pied de cette taille là
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce panar
gigantesque donc ça c'est pas une preuve
des géants dont ils nous ont parlé avant
c'est une preuve d'une autre race de
géante complètement différent et pareil
pour celle d'avant l'empreinte d'avant
là c'est la preuve de l'existence d'une
race de géante complètement différente
de cette race de géant qui faisait 2m50
3 mètres de haut ça c'est une race de
géant qui fait 4-5 mètres de haut là
c'est complètement différent ça a rien à
voir
si on continue les empreintes qui
suivent
pas vers le monde de 100g
je veux dire ils se sont même pas fait
chier essayer de cacher le fait que
c'était sculpté l'avoue de plantaire
pareil elle est pas elle est pas très
convaincante 1 2 3 4 à il y a peut-être
un cinquième petit orteil là mais bref
encore une fois gros orteil opposable
pourquoi comment donc ça ou alors c'est
encore une fois de l'érosion mais enfin
clairement il y a il y a un phénomène
qui a creusé cette empreinte en fait on
voit bien que cette empreinte elle est
creusée soit soit par l'érosion et c'est
une pareille d'olive soit par un être
humain et c'est un fake vous voyez il y
a des empreintes là on voit on a l'air
d'être dans un pays je sais pas juste à
vue de juste à vue de
des des vêtements on m'a l'air d'être
dans un pays d'Orient je sais pas
exactement lequel je sais pas si on est
au Moyen-Orient
mais il y a des empreintes de Mahomet
qui ont été sculptés des empreintes de
Mahomet qui sont donc des empreintes de
piéger géants mais ce sont des
empreintes sculptées qui sont vénérés
comme étant les empreintes de Mahomet
bon pourquoi pas mais ce sont des
empreintes sculptées
ça c'est une empreinte qui n'a même pas
d'orteil je vais pas m'arrêter dessus
donc celle là c'est celle qui est dans
le granit donc elle est clairement fake
parce que de toute façon il n'existe
aucune version de la physique la plus
élémentaire qui permet à une empreinte
comme ça de se former
sous le fait d'un pied cet empreinte de
pied à une chaussure je vous laisse
réfléchir là-dessus
cet empreinte ça il me semble que c'est
une empreinte de Mahomet voilà donc on
le sait qu'elles sont sculptées et c'est
et c'est pas compliqué de voir qu'elle
est sculptée cet empreinte comment ça se
fait qu'il y a un rond autour
c'est pas compliqué de voir que cette
empreinte est sculptée il y a un rond
qui a été sculpté autour comment cette
empreinte a fini au fond d'un rond si le
rond lui-même n'a pas été sculpté avant
tu peux baisser là du BEPC
[Rires]
bon bref donc ça c'est des choses qui
sont vénérées c'est des choses c'est des
objets de vénération comme on le voit
très bien sur cette photo je pense enfin
je pense que c'est une empreinte de
Mahomet c'est peut-être une empreinte de
Bouddha puisqu'ils font aussi ça les
empreintes de Bouddha qui était du non
moins géant Bouddha d'ailleurs il faut
bien préciser que Bouddha était géant
dans la mythologie
mais ça c'est ça n'a pu apparaître qu'en
étant sculpté et il le savent c'est le
symbole qui est important ils le savent
très bien c'est pareil avec la dent du
Bouddha la dent d'une au moins j'ai en
Bouddha
dont on a des on en a des dents on en a
plusieurs dans la je vous en ai mis deux
pour lesquelles on a des images celle-là
c'est une dent de cheval
c'est pas une dent de Bouddha et
celle-là c'est une dent on voit les deux
croissants on voit la morphologie à deux
croissants c'est une bande
d'artiodactyle probablement de vache
voilà
donc mais ils le savent très bien que ce
sont pas des dents de Bouddha c'est des
dents de Bouddha enfin en tout cas les
moines qui sont en charge de garder ses
dents ils le savent très bien c'est
juste le symbole qui est important
donc c'est je ne froid ce personne en
disant ça ils sont tout à fait au
courant de ce qui se passe contrairement
à ceux qui ont fait ce enfin
contrairement à ce qu'essaye de faire
croire les gens qui ont fait ce
documentaire parce que je refuse de
croire encore une fois que ce
documentaire a été fait avec honnêteté
intellectuel
qu'est-ce que je disais
check l'oracle a parlé
je vous disais donc la Bible comme
argent comptant BIM la Bible comme
argent comptant parce que le mythe des
géants c'est de là qui vient il vient
pour justifier l'existence de la Genèse
enfin des mythes de la Bible commençons
par cela ah oui commençons commençons
par les preuves les plus fortes la Bible
vous pouvez regarder que Goliath est pas
si grand que ça non plus
hein
le grand prêtre du n'importe quoi
le grand prêtre du n'importe quoi qui a
repris des théories qui sont vieilles de
plusieurs centaines d'années à son
compte
et je le sais parce que il y a un livre
qui est sorti tout récemment qui
s'appelle alien artifact et qui démontre
en fait par Chris obec qui m'a gentiment
envoyé l'extrait que je suis en train de
vous montrer
et qui démontre que en fait les théories
sur les anciens astronautes et autres
voilà les aliens anciens et les anciens
astronautes et l'Atlantide et tout ça en
fait enfin ça a des racines très
racistes et très anciennes et voyez là
il parle notamment de Alfred despillar
écrivain français de 1865 et il compare
le texte d'Alfred espillard de 1865 avec
le texte de Drake qui est un autre
prophète de la
des anciens astronautes et il fait une
comparaison c'est quasiment au mot près
vous voyez il parle notamment des géants
il parle des géants et ça c'est en fait
il compare le texte d'espillard à celui
de Drake de 1964 et on voit au mot près
quasiment qu'ils ont repris les mêmes
idées
voilà la race la race des maîtres la
race des maîtres européens voilà la
racine raciste du truc à la base c'était
fait pour justifier des
une mythologie raciste enfin c'était
pour justifier une vision raciste du
monde donc on retrouve ça et donc il y a
aussi vandani Ken qui est cité dans ce
livre un peu plus loin
notamment sur le voilà les statuts de
l'île de Pâques qui ont été
qui ont été reprises à mettre maintes
fois et vous avez vantanicaine et son
chariot of the god 1968 qui font partie
du lot qui ont notamment repompé l'idée
du fait que les êtres humains ou du
moins de certains ancêtres des êtres
humains notamment les géants viendraient
des étoiles
et en fait il y a même il y a surtout ce
côté en fait les les êtres humains
qui ne qui viennent d'Amérique notamment
par exemple ceux de Nasca donc les
Indiens d'Amérique comme par exemple
ceux de NASCAR ou de Paracas vous savez
ceux qui ont les ce qui ont la boîte
crânienne allongée
et bien c'est les êtres humains ne
seraient pas totalement d'origine
terrestre vous comprenez les seules
vrais humains qu'il y a sur terre ce
sont les Européens c'est ce que disent
toutes ces auteurs des années 1800 qui
ont été quasi plagiés par les auteurs
des années 60 tel vente Daniken et Drake
les auteurs des années 1800 qui vivaient
dans un bon monde bien colonial ils ont
été quasiment plagiés et eux ce qu'il
disait c'était que évidemment les
Indiens d'Amérique ne peuvent pas être
de même origine ils ne peuvent pas être
de sang purs vous comprenez ils viennent
d'ailleurs et ça ça se retrace dans des
écrits qui remontent je vais vous
montrer juste ici
ça se retrace dans des écrits qui datent
de au moins jusqu'en 1866 encore un
Français d'ailleurs Jules Negron qui
nous dit que les races Aztèques
d'Amérique même soldat d'Afrique ils
viennent de la lune ils ne peuvent pas
avoir le même droit à posséder la terre
que les Européens puisqu'ils ne viennent
pas de la terre et donc on retrouve ça
aujourd'hui dans toutes les
interprétations des crânes des crânes
allongés d'Amérique
donc les crânes de Paracas et les crânes
par exemple de Nasca qui sont qui juste
parce qu'ils sont allongés et on sait
très bien comment ils faisaient c'était
c'est juste une déformation qui était
appliquée à la naissance des bébés il y
a pas de il y a pas de il y a rien
d'extraordinaire dans ce qu'ils font là
ces crâne déformé ce sont la preuve Si
vous voulez que c'était une race
extraterrestre ou qu'ils essayaient
d'imiter une race extraterrestre aussi
qu'ils essayaient d'imiter l'anatomie
d'une race extraterrestre
et ben ça ça retrace ses origines dans
des ouvrages qui datent de la moitié du
19e siècle dans un monde complètement
colonial complètement
ultra raciste qui totalement essayait
d'expliquer par ces cosmogonies une
origine une de justifier que le monde
appartient aux Européens
c'est moche c'est moche bah oui ben
vente d'annicken et Drake ils sont
complètement à les pomper là dedans au
point que Drake alors il le fait pas
pour vendre Daniken mais au point que
pour Drake il arrive à faire une
comparaison texte à texte donc je vous
mettrai ça pareil en description vous
pourrez aller le lire c'est très
intéressant c'est juste quelques
extraits c'est pas tout le livre mais
voilà en tout cas je suis je remercie
Chris au bec de m'avoir envoyé parce que
ça a été très éclairant comme lecture
et puis pour en revenir au crâne allongé
juste vite fait je vous montre des
extraits d'une petite vidéo ou en fait
quand on vous annonce que les crânes
allongés ont une capacité crânienne très
élevée bien plus élevée deux fois et
demi plus élevé que celle d'un être
humain normal bah c'est pas compliqué à
vérifier c'est de la géométrie
élémentaire c'est la géométrie
élémentaire un crâne enfin du moins une
boîte crânienne humaine allongée c'est
rien de plus qu'une sereine plus qu'un
ellipsoïde donc c'est la même façon de
mesurer le volume qu'un ballon de rugby
donc c'est très facile en fait de
vérifier cette affirmation il suffit de
trouver une photo d'un crâne avec une
barre d'échelle de la mesurer comme si
c'était un ellipsoïde donc vous mesurez
les deux diamètres comme un ellipsoïde
vous utilisez l'équation de base qu'on
vous a normalement appris au collège
mais que vous pouvez retrouver en la
Google Home
vous pouvez très facilement la retrouver
en la Google en cette équation vous
utilisez l'équation pour avec les deux
rayons c'est 4/3 de PI je sais plus quoi
bref je me rappelle plus moi-même je me
rappelle plus je la Google vous googleez
volume ellipsoïde on vous donne
l'équation vous rentrez vos mesures et
ça vous donne un volume et paf le volume
c'est 1400 cm3 comme un être humain
normal
étonnant non
ou 1000 ce que j'avais trouvé là dans la
vidéo que je vous mets je crois que
c'est 1500 cm3 mais ça reste dans la
gamme de variation des êtres humains
normal qui monte jusqu'à 1600 donc
être humain normaux toujours toujours
toujours toujours toujours toujours
toujours toujours
bon bref on va écouter donc l'opinion de
quelqu'un qui a recompé ses idées sur
des sur des Européens racistes du XIXe
siècle
voilà
on pourrait on pourrait me rétorquer que
Darwin était aussi un Européen raciste
du 19e siècle oui mais on les
évolutionniste d'aujourd'hui n'ont pas
ne recopie pas Darwin mot à mot ça c'est
des choses que je n'arrête pas de
répéter c'est que si vous citez encore
Darwin aujourd'hui
c'est que vous vous êtes perdus en
chemin
la seule raison qu'un pour laquelle un
scientifique citerait Darwin c'est dans
un contexte d'histoire des sciences
c'est à dire pour rappeler l'origine de
la théorie c'est tout dans ce que Darwin
a dit il y a quasiment plus rien qui est
valide il y a le mécanisme de la
sélection naturelle sur lequel on a
construit mais une cathédrale depuis
cité Darwin Darwin c'est genre le
premier pavé de la cathédrale enfin
c'est le premier pavé des fondations de
la cathédrale même à ce niveau là depuis
il y a une cathédrale qui a été
construit au dessus et s'imaginer que
les scientifiques cite encore Darwin de
façon sérieuse c'est s'imaginer que on
ne voit que ce pavé là et qu'on ignore
la cathédrale c'est n'importe quoi donc
aujourd'hui il y a plus de scientifiques
sérieux qui vous citrons Darwin comme
étant argent comptant hors de question
ça n'existe pas
bref il y a que les créationsnistes qui
citent encore Darwin en s'imaginant que
les scientifiques pensent que c'est
argent comptant
on retrouve la même chose en Egypte où
les textes portant sur les pyramides
révèle que certaines dieux étaient
géants par rapport et on vous montre des
statues
où on a représenté des gens en grand
vous savez ça n'a aucune valeur
symbolique c'est du encore une fois les
Égyptiens étaient trop cons pour
utiliser des symboles c'est ça qu'on est
c'est ça qu'on est en train de vous
montrer avec cette photo cette photo
elle est en train de vous montrer les
Égyptiens ont construit des grandes
statues pour représenter des grandes
personnes
il y a aucune valeur symbolique au fait
de représenter un être humain géant et
d'ailleurs sans vouloir
je veux pas trop m'avancer mais il me
semble que si vous mesurez les
proportions des statuts en fait elles
sont pas humaines les comme la tête est
plus loin du sol ils les ont fait plus
grosses ils ont fait les têtes plus
grosses parce que du coup pour adapter
la perspective en fait pour que vu du
sol la tête et l'air proportionnée si je
me rappelle bien vous c'est pas le cas
peut-être de ces statuts là mais je me
semble qu'il y a certaines statues
égyptiennes les jolies les égyptologues
qui me regardent pour confirmer ou
infirmer ce que je viens de dire parce
que je suis pas sûr mais bref les
proportions du coup ne seraient pas
celle d'un humain géant c'est là où je
vais en venir c'est quoi qu'il arrive
encore une fois on aurait un humain qui
est au mieux proportionné un être humain
géant qui serait au mieux proportionné
comme un être humain normal et dans ce
cas là comme je vous ai dit ça ne marche
pas
donc et là en gros on est en train de
daigner aux Égyptiens une pensée
symbolique
et la pensée symbolique c'est quand même
un gros signe une un des symptômes de
l'intelligence donc on est en train de
nier l'intelligence des Égyptiens
alors pourquoi pas aux États-Unis
bah là je vous renvoie Julien Doui et
Jean-Louis lequelclec et à tous leurs
travaux
qui en fait les travaux de Julien douit
et Jean-Louis Le Coex se sont des
mythologistes
qui travaillent en France je crois
qu'ils sont à la Sorbonne
Julien Denis mythologie juste pour vous
montrer un exemple en fait pourquoi on
retrouve les mêmes mythologies partout
dans le monde bah ce que nous disent
Julien Douy et Jean-Louis lequelc
c'est qu'en fait
c'est qu'en fait toutes ces mythologies
donc ils sont représentées par des
chiffres ici ont un ancêtre en commun
généralement généralement qui remonte
d'après encore une fois Julien Louis et
Jean-Louis lequelex attend s'être en
commun remonte en fait à l'époque où les
humains ont quitté l'Afrique donc ça
correspond à la haute en Africa hors
d'Afrique la marche hors d'Afrique donc
c'est généralement un ancêtre qui est un
ancêtre à tous les à tous ces mythes
dispersés à travers le monde qui aurait
à peu près 100 120 000 ans voilà c'est
pour ça que le monde entier a et donc ce
mythe a évidemment un ancêtre africain
donc on le retrouve aussi en Afrique
c'est un mythe qui était africain à la
base mais quand ils se sont dispersés à
travers le monde et ben on voit la
dispersion du mythe et la
diversification surtout du mythe qui
commence à ce moment là puisque les
populations commencent à se répandre si
loin dans le monde qu'elles n'ont plus
de communication entre elles
et donc là on voit une énorme
diversification du mythe et vous avez
généralement un autre point de
divergence qui correspond à l'arrivée en
Amérique donc par exemple
ici on vous montre un mythe qui
correspond au mythe de la chasse
cosmique et vous voyez que ici vous avez
tous les mythes américains qui sont
réunis dans une seule branche évolutive
parce que ici vous avez la dispersion
des êtres humains en Amérique il y a
entre
24 et 12000 ans c'est très débattu si
c'était plus 24 + 12000 maintenant on
est plus à 24000 ans mais bref ici vous
avez un événement de dispersion d'un
mythe unique venu de Razi vous voyez le
groupe frère et l'euras ici et ce mythe
c'est dispersé en Amérique où il sait
une fois de plus PAM diversifié au fur
et à mesure que les humains
colonisaient l'Amérique et puisqu'on
nous parlait des Inuits vous voyez les
Inuits ils sont là l'Amérique arctique
ils ont leur propre lots de mythes qui
est lui-même dérivé du mi-temps systral
arrivé en Amérique et je me demande si
on a pas est-ce qu'on a l'Amérique du
Sud
[Musique]
on n'a pas l'Amérique du Sud pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi et donc après vous
avez d'autres mouvements après ça reste
des hypothèses phylogénétiques donc
évidemment vous avez quelques petites
incohérences ici et là mais globalement
vous voyez une histoire assez cohérente
qui se passe au milieu il est possible
aussi qu'il y ait des mythes qui ont
migré plus tard avec l'arrivée notamment
des des
Vikings par exemple il est possible
qu'il y a eu des transmissions de mythes
à ce moment là entre l'Eurasie et entre
le rasi et l'Amérique du Nord il est
possible qu'il y ait des mythes qui est
convergé vers une morphologie entre
guillemets une mythologie proche de
celle d'un mythe asiatique bon ce sont
des choses qui peuvent arriver mais bref
l'Amérique du Sud est là donc vous voyez
ça forme un Cloud avec un autre mythe
une autre catégorie de mythes d'Amérique
du Nord bref c'était peut-être pas la
chasse cosmique c'était peut-être pas le
meilleur exemple mais je trouve qu'elle
illustre quand même assez bien mais là
évidemment il fallait que je vous trouve
une image vite fait donc évidemment mais
il y en a plein ça c'est que la chasse
cosmique mais il y en a plein d'autres
des mythes comme ça
clients qui ont tous évolué de la même
manière c'est surtout ça qui est
absolument incroyable avec ce que Julien
douillet et Jean-Louis Lequellec ont
accompli c'est qu'en fait à chaque fois
l'histoire et la même vous avez un
ancêtre en commun d'un mythe en Afrique
ça marche avec les dragons par exemple
j'en avais parlé la dernière fois quand
je parlais des dragons donc ça marche
avec les dragons la vidéo les Dino fake
où on nous dit ah pourquoi toutes les
cultures ont un mythe de dragon bah même
même histoire origin africaine
dispersion il y a 100 000 ans dans le
monde dispersion en Amérique du Nord il
y avait 24000 ans et pouf le monde
entier se retrouve avec des histoires de
dragon directement irrités directement
hérité pardon de d'un mythe ancestral
qui était un serpent arc-en-ciel à la
base pour les dragons
donc c'est pareil pour le mythe des
dragons c'est pareil pour tous les
mythes et récemment Jean-Louis lequelc a
sorti un livre qui en fait
parle de l'émergence du mythe de
l'émergence c'est-à-dire l'origine même
de l'humanité et pareil même histoire
l'origine même de l'humanité la Genèse
puisqu'on en parle le mythe de la
jeunesse c'est pas du tout un mythe
récent c'est pas du tout la Bible qui
l'a inventé le mythe de la Genèse c'est
un mythe qui est excessivement ancien
qui est apparu en Afrique qui a déjà
connu une première phase de
diversification en Afrique ou en fait ce
que montre Jean-Louis lequelexe c'est
que à la base le mythe c'était une
émergence venant du sol la Terre mère
faisait émerger l'être humain et en fait
le mythe s'est retourné en Afrique
notamment en Afrique du Nord en Afrique
du Nord le mythe s'est retourné en fait
au lieu d'émerger du sol le l'être
humain s'est mis à émerger du ciel et là
ça doit vous et là ça vous rappelle un
peu plus ce qu'on trouve dans la Bible
et ça c'était c'est un événement
évolutif qui avait déjà eu lieu en
Afrique avant la sortie d'Afrique donc
c'est plus vieux que 100 000 ans
et ouais bah oui bah oui quand on se dit
c'est beaucoup plus c'est beaucoup plus
plausible comme histoire que de dire bah
non il y avait des géants partout alors
il y avait évidemment tout le monde a
des histoires de géant non non non non
c'est un ancêtre en commun encore une
fois c'est une histoire évolutive c'est
un ancêtre en commun et on voit c'est ce
qui a d'extraordinaire avec ces
histoires c'est que c'est pas juste des
histoires c'est vraiment ce que font le
Québec et du I c'est qu'il reconstruise
l'histoire des mythes et que cette
histoire des mythes des mythologies
ce superpose parfaitement à l'histoire
évolutive humaine ce superpos enfin
l'histoire évolutive humaine telle que
racontée par l'archéologie elle se
superpose à l'histoire évolutive humaine
telle que racontée par la génétique elle
se superpose à l'histoire de l'évolution
des langages aussi
et dans un univers où cette histoire ou
des géants ont existé et sont à
l'origine du mythe des géants il n'y a
aucune raison pour lesquelles ces
histoires devraient superposer la
génétique devrait nous parler de devrait
nous dire hé regardez il y a des gènes
de gigantisme chez nos il y a des gènes
de gigantisme endormis chez les humains
modernes notamment chez les Amérindiens
ça n'existe pas
le registre fossile devrait nous montrer
définitivement des énormes crânes qu'on
devrait trouver partout ça n'existe pas
surtout si c'est géant ils étaient
partout ça n'existe pas il y a que des
Photoshop dégueulasses et des fossiles
qui ont été réinterprétés comme étant
des mammouths vous avez
la vous avez donc il y a la génétique la
paléontologie l'histoire de la
linguistique il y a aucune raison pour
laquelle la langue des géants n'est
laissé aucune trace dans notre
linguistique s'il y avait
une civilisation de géants qui
recouvrait le monde cette civilisation
de géant devait avoir la même langue
pour qu'il construise justement tous la
même chose à des cailloux en triangle
pourquoi il y a aucune trace de ça dans
nos langages pourquoi au contraire on
voit des langues aussi différentes que
celle des Bushmen que celle des
Amérindiens et que celle des
Indo-Européens pourquoi
pourquoi les langages humains ne sont
pas tous unifiés plus unifié que ça en
tout cas
ça n'a aucun sens de rajouter des géants
dans le mix
et ceci n'est pas un géant c'est un
poulpe
on essaie de vous faire passer ça pour
un géant mais c'est un poulpe
[Musique]
ont-elles pu disparaître
comment toutes les preuves ont-ils pu
disparaître toutes les preuves ont
disparu comme par hasard comme par
hasard et bien toutes les preuves n'ont
pas disparu très chers amis je sais
maintenant que je vous révèle le poteau
rose toutes les preuves n'ont pas
disparu il nous reste bel et bien des
fossiles de géants alors on va commencer
alors des fossiles de géant je vais
expliquer ce que je veux dire par
fossile de géant il nous reste des
fossiles de géants dans le sens où les
gens avant de connaître le concept de
dinosaures
ou avant de connaître le concept de
mammouth en l'occurrence ça va être plus
du mammouth comme je vous l'ai déjà dit
donc avant de connaître le concept de
dinosaures le concept de mammouth le
concept de fossiles et bien les gens
trouver des fossiles
et ces fossiles bah il les interprétés
comme ils pouvaient et comme en
l'occurrence le mythe des géants était
prépondérant rapport à la Bible et tout
ça le mythe des géants était
prépondérant bah on avait tendance à un
peu tout interpréter comme étant du
géant même quand cela allait en dépit du
bon sens je vous rappelle cette dent
cette dent interpréter comme un humain
géant alors qu'elle n'a rien à voir avec
une dent humaine et même à l'époque ils
auraient dû s'en rendre compte je veux
dire même à l'époque ils auraient dû
regarder cette dent de mammouth et au
lieu d'en dire que c'était un géant ils
auraient dû demander à leur pote à côté
d'eux d'ouvrir la bouche et de comparer
mais non ils ont pas fait ça parce que à
l'époque fallait surtout pas remettre ça
en question
non bref les gens ils trouvaient des
fossiles et ces fossiles il les
interprétaient comme ils pouvaient à
savoir qu'il les interprétaient comme
étant des géants et aujourd'hui
maintenant qu'on a cette connaissance
bah on revient sur cette preuve sur ses
preuves de l'existence des géants et ses
preuves de l'existence des géants n'ont
pas disparu contrairement à ce qu'on va
essayer de vous faire croire là dans ce
documentaire elles ont pas disparu
l'épreuve de l'existence des géants
elles existent toujours on les a
toujours on les a conservés en tout cas
une partie d'entre elles et quand on les
regarde avec notre œil de scientifique
moderne avec nos connaissances acquises
avec l'anatomie comparée comme outil
pour les réinterpréter et bien on se
rend compte que ces fossiles de géants
ne sont absolument pas des fossiles de
géants regardez ça c'est tous les
fossiles qui des exemples de fossiles
qui ont été trouvés avant l'air
scientifique donc ça c'était interprété
comme étant un serpent mais en fait
c'était une ammonite là vous voyez
encore une ammonite affichée dans une
église avec les gravures de l'époque qui
décrivent que c'est une corde d'amont si
je me si je ne m'abuse
vous avez là les fossiles qui ont été
découverts par l'homme de Néandertal
donc tout ça celui-là il a même été
taillé en outil c'est vous dire si
l'homme donnaitandertal savait qu'il
était là c'est possible puisqu'il l'a
taillé en outil donc tout ça ça a été
découvert vous voyez Moustérien
magdalenia ça a été découvert alors
Néandertal pour le Moustérien après pour
l'acheter un c'est plus vieux du coup
c'est encore plus vieux que Néandertal
et magdalenya c'est plus jeune que
Néandertal mais tout ça c'est c'est du
Paléolithique donc ça a été découvert
par Néandertal et Cro-Magnon et même
avant ça du coup les cornes d'amont les
dents de requins qui étaient interprétés
comme des glossopètres c'est à dire des
des
langues pétrifiées généralement de
serpent vous voyez un mégalodon ici
magnifique donc un mégalodon qui a été
trouvé je sais pas au 16e siècle un truc
comme ça
à Malte
vous avez donc les les pierres d'orage
qui étaient en fait des bélénite qui est
pareil était trouvé avant vous avez
cette tombe du Paléolithique ou du
Mésolithique non c'est l'âge du bronze
c'est l'âge du bronze qui est ici donc
l'âge du bronze il me semble que moi non
c'est plus jeune que le Mésolithique
l'âge du bronze mais bref c'est vieux
c'est vieux c'est press scientifique et
pourtant vous avez tous ces oursins
fossiles qui ont été accumulés dans
cette tombe de façon très symbolique
donc les gens trouvaient des fossiles
avant et donc il trouvait aussi des
ossements et on va essayer de passer
directement aux ossements donc certains
ossements comme ce crâne de rhinocéros
était interprété comme un crâne de
dragon
cette ce crâne d'ours ici de ours des
cavernes comparé ici donc là c'est la
gravure d'époque et comparé à un crâne
d'ours des cavernes vous voyez c'est
très reconnaissable bon bah ça c'était
aussi interprété comme un crâne de
dragon mais en fait c'était un ours des
cavernes et donc les géants qui ne
peuvent pas être juste des versions
vachement plus grandes des
êtres humains modernes contrairement à
ce que vous suggère cette image et ben
vous aviez aussi des crins des vous avez
la majorité d'ailleurs des fossiles qui
étaient interprétés comme appartenant à
des géants et donc la paire de la paire
de testicules cosmique
le fameux scrotum humanum géant
qui est bon qui était à l'époque ils ont
déjà interprété ça comme étant un fémur
en fait c'est
c'est d'arrêt de neige qui en a parlé
récemment le paléontologue d'arène neige
qui en a parlé récemment il y a jamais
été question à aucun moment que
quelqu'un l'interprète comme étant un
véritable scrotum humain pétrifié ça
ressemble à un scrotum humain mais déjà
à l'époque ils avaient ils avaient quand
même tilté que c'était un fémur que
c'était une tête une extrémité distale
de fémur mais comme ils connaissait pas
les dinosaures bah ils ont quand même
dit que c'était un géant un humain géant
donc mais au final au final donc c'était
un dinosaure ça a été à identifié comme
étant un dinosaure donc il y a plein
d'exemples comme ça et donc Eric
buffeteau qui est celui qui a fait cette
présentation PowerPoint que je vous
montre là
Eric busto paléontologue français il a
écrit tout un bouquin qui s'appelle
fossile et croyances populaires comme
c'est comme ce PowerPoint où il donne
plein d'autres exemples de trucs qui ont
été interprétés comme des géants vous
avez évidemment l'histoire des Cyclopes
allez j'oubliais l'histoire des Cyclopes
bon ça par contre ça par contre c'est un
mythe qu'il faut casser c'est que il y a
jamais personne qui plus la preuve que
l'histoire des Cyclopes venait de la
mauvaise interprétation des crânes
d'éléphant c'est il y a des en Sicile en
Sicile il y avait une petite une espèce
de petit éléphant qui s'appelle
paléolocsodopalconeri l'éléphant Nancy
qui a laissé des crânes et la légende
raconte qu'en gros c'est en trouvant ses
crâne que les marins se sont imaginés
voir des Cyclopes parce qu'en fait les
éléphants ils ont un gros trou au milieu
du front pour l'insertion de la trompe
donc ça ressemble très pour très à un
œil de Cyclope et à l'inverse on voit
quasiment pas le trou pour les yeux chez
les éléphants puisque les éléphants ont
des tout petits yeux donc on voit pas le
trou pour les yeux mais par contre on
voit bien le trou pour le on voit très
très très très bien le trou
pour le pour l'insertion de la trompe je
bafouille parce que je suis en train de
me dire que il y a une image là voilà
donc j'ai même pas besoin de me faire
chier à vous expliquer voyez là les yeux
sont là le trou pour les yeux et là donc
il est à peine marqué mais par contre
vous avez un énorme trou pour la trompe
donc ça ça aurait donné naissance au
mythe des Cyclopes puisque ça ressemble
effectivement à l'idée qu'on se freine
d'un crâne de Cyclope il y a jamais eu
de preuves de ça dans le sens où on n'a
jamais trouvé aucun texte décrivant
Akram d'éléphant mais le qualifiant de
de crâne de Cyclope
on n'a jamais on a même je crois même
pas qu'on est le moindre texte comme
quoi des marins et trouver des crânes
enfin des squelettes tout court en fait
donc on ne sait même pas s'ils étaient
réellement s'ils avaient réellement
découvert ces choses là
enfin c'est faux cils là les marins
grecs bref c'est juste pour dire c'est
juste pour dire que il y a plein de il y
a plein d'histoires de géants en fait
qui traînent dans la littérature
et dont on retrouve encore les restes
matériaux aujourd'hui et c'est ça qui
est important les restes matériels
pardon aujourd'hui il y en a plein donc
là par exemple le géant le géant du
tique en Tunisie celui qui avait été
décrit par Saint-Augustin vous avez une
image il nous reste une chose il nous
reste une image et cette image montre
clairement la dent d'un éléphant fossile
vous avez le géant qui a été découvert
en 1643 à Bruges dans les Flandres on en
a encore les restes et quand on regarde
les restes en question et bien on se
rend compte qu'il s'agit de proposition
donc là vous voyez c'est le fémur qui
est là
donc le fémur qui est là existe encore
il existe encore ce cette hausse enfin
ces ossements qui ont été découvert en
1643 à Bruges existe encore ils sont
encore conservés et c'est définitivement
de l'os d'éléphant on reconnaît bien le
fémur d'un éléphant à l'absence total de
boss sur les côtés si vous regardez un
fémur de n'importe quel autre animal il
y a des boss sur les côtés qu'on appelle
des trochanter les éléphants n'en ont
pas et ça c'est très caractéristique des
éléphants on a le géant de riden dont on
a retrouvé aussi des restes fossilisés
qui appartiennent à quoi je vous le
donne en mille a du mammouth c'est écrit
à l'arrière
vous avez alors pas dans le genre
fossile donc je vais peut-être revenir
après à celui là vous avez le géant
l'estrigons
dans mon collègue Marco Romano a
retrouvé les restes
à retrouver des restes dans un musée et
surprise c'est encore de l'éléphant
regardez ils sont là pas le géant de
l'esrigon qui est en fait un fémur de
mammouth encore une fois pourquoi parce
qu'il y a aucune des bosses
aucun des trois cancer en fait
qui caractérise enfin l'absence de
trochanter est très évidente et
caractérise les éléphants et évidemment
on a très célèbre géant français tuto
Bocuse qui a été découvert dans le sud
de la France et donc vous pouvez voir ce
qu'il reste aujourd'hui au Muséum
d'histoire naturelle de Paris c'est à
dire un gros morceau de fémur et un
autre morceau d'os il y a toujours écrit
etuto Bocuse dessus c'est pour ça qu'on
est sûr donc tu es autobocus c'est censé
être un géant qui a été découvert dans
les années 1600 et des dans le sud de la
France et alors on a pu le ré-identifier
parce qu'on a conservé ces restes au
Muséum d'histoire naturelle de Paris
parce que ça reste inclus une dent qui
n'est définitivement pas une dent
humaine puisqu'elle a vous voyez un LOF
de l'O les dents humaines n'ont pas de
l'offre elles ont des cupides mais c'est
le de l'offre sont très très
symptomatiques encore une fois des
promossiliens c'est à dire des cousins
des éléphants et en l'occurrence cette
dent à la même pu être identifiée à un
dino terium c'est-à-dire un grand robot
Cydia qui vivait à l'oligosène et au
milieu scène
entre autres dans nos régions mais en
fait il avait une distribution quasiment
mondiale à part en Amérique du Nord donc
encore une fois un géant dont on a
conservé les traces il y a de la
littérature accessible en français à son
encontre des mammouths des hommes et
aussi l'article de James bourg de 1900
de 1985 d'où j'ai extrait 7 photos il y
a de la littérature en français il y a
littéralement aucune excuse pour pas
savoir ça et tout ça a été résumé très
très bien dès les années 1700 dès les
années 1700 regarder 1812 cette édition
date de 1812 c'est la je sais pas si
c'est la première édition je pense pas
mais bref les recherches sur les
ossements de quadrupède sur les osmans
fossiles de quadrupède de cuviers il y a
une liste longue comme le bras de géant
que cuvier a réinterprété comme étant
des comme étant des restes en fait
d'éléphants donc là
vous voyez il en fait une liste il y a
le 7e ça commence là à 1 2 morceaux de
mâchoire inférieure dont un pesant 6
livres contenant deux molaires et la
place de deux autres le plus grand de 12
livres et une entière trop cassée chaque
dent et 4 racines et trois grandes comme
le pied
deux vertèbres dans une 3 d'épaisseur et
donc il y a celui de Valence que j'ai
mis là donc monsieur de Jussieu m'a dit
avoir vu autrefois des eaux d'éléphants
suspendus dans une église de Valence
qu'on dit qu'on y dit soi-disant de
géants et il les réinterprète comme
étant du mammouth
donc regardez et là il y en a plein des
comme ça des donc vous chercherez vous
pourrez aller voir je vous mettrai ça en
description un petit lien pour le
télécharger tout est dans les les
recherches sur les ossements fossiles de
Cuvier et on le sait depuis 1800 1812 et
donc depuis 1812d la quasi-totalité des
restes de géants qui étaient qui étaient
gardés notamment dans des églises et qui
ont ensuite été déplacés dans des musées
c'est pour ça qu'on les retrouve encore
aujourd'hui dans les musées mais à la
base ils étaient gardés dans des églises
comme étant des ossements de seins et
les preuves justement que les récits
bibliques étaient vrais et ben en fait
ils ont été déménagés dans les musées
parce que on s'est rendu compte que
c'était juste des ossements de
quadrupède fossiles notamment de
mammouth
voilà voilà et puis et puis dans l'autre
dans d'autres dans une autre catégorie
on a par exemple le géant reinir qui
vivait à zastron donc rahnir du veinard
qui en a pas eu de veine donc
qui vivait à zastron en Afrique du Sud
c'est c'était aussi un géant rainière du
veinard parce que il a quand même réussi
avec son nom moins géant fusil à chasser
le diable lui-même de la montagne et ce
faisant il a fait un trou de plusieurs
mètres de diamètre dans la montagne donc
si vous vous avez qu'à Google les Astron
Z a S TR o n zastro et vous verrez le
trou que rahnir a fait dans la montagne
et vous verrez que Ryanair était un
géant puisque il a fait un trou géant
dans la montagne avec son fusil géant
sauf que quand on regarde la tombe du
bon règne
[Rires]
la solidité des preuves
donc ça c'est qu'un exemple c'est c'est
des tout petits exemples une poignée
juste une poignée comme je vous dis il y
en a des dizaines dans les recherches
d'ossements fossiles de Cuvier alors je
vais pas vous faire toute la liste il a
vraiment bien des bunks et le truc pour
le coup c'est juste une poignée des
arguments et c'est aussi pour vous
montrer parce qu'on va évidemment
essayer de vous convaincre dans ce
documentaire les scientifiques cachent
la vérité parce que ça peut ça ne peut
que passer par là cette histoire de mec
qu'est-il arrivé aux preuves ça va
passer par mesquetti il arrivait aux
preuves bah les scientifiques les ont
cachés parce que ça dérange l'évolution
ça dérange la théorie de l'évolution le
dogme de la théorie de l'évolution non
non les preuves sont pas cachés les
preuves sont dans les musées les preuves
ont été publiées donc rendus public
et c'est juste que vous vous gourrez
monumentalement l'épreuve sont tellement
public que vous voyez il y a même un
livre en français là faut aussi les
croyances populaires c'est la deuxième
fois en moins de deux mois que je le
recommande parce que c'est de la bonne
il faut le lire ce livre il faut le lire
et tout était là donc aucune excuse
absolument zéro excuse pour ne pas vous
être renseigné très cher ami de chez
Gaïa
encore un auteur encore un autoproclamé
ont été découverts toujours pas toujours
pas de barre d'échelle
c'est vrai qu'il a l'air vachement grand
ce monsieur regarde ah bah non
là on va surtout pas vous montrer les
jambes de c'est bien c'est que là on a
une barre d'échelle pour une fois mais
on va surtout pas vous montrer les
jambes du bazar parce qu'on risquerait
de se rendre compte qu'il est surélevé
en fait sur un sur un pédestal
9 pieds toujours on est toujours sur des
trucs huit pieds 9 pieds donc on reste
encore une fois dans la gamme
dans la gamme athlète de très grande
taille voire gigantisme pathologique
mais on est toujours pas sortis on nous
a toujours pas sortis le mec de 4C vous
savez il suffirait de pas loin il
suffirait d'un truc un être humain à
squelette d'être humain de 5 mètres de
haut
et bon on le sait que il y a des géants
qui ont existé maintenant au lieu de ça
on nous montre des êtres humains on nous
montre pas les pieds là celui-là il est
clairement sur un pédestal
[Musique]
encore des coupures de presse qui datent
de Mathusalem écrites par des gens qui
ne sont pas des scientifiques comme
étant des preuves alors là celui-là il
est intéressant on nous dit 2000 cm3 de
volume contre 1400 centimètres cubes en
moyenne pour un être humain ok où est la
photo du crâne qui a fait la mesure où a
été fait la mesure personne ne le sait
et on ne vous le dira pas
on est obligé de les croire sur parole
on est obligé de croire sur parole une
coupure de presse alors qui vous dit qui
vous dit parce que on nous dit le
cerveau avait une capacité de 2000 cm3
ok c'est plus gros qu'un cerveau humain
moderne mais ça a été mesuré comment ça
a été mesuré au pifomètre ça a été
mesuré avec des graines de moutarde ça a
été mesuré avec de l'eau ça a été mesuré
en faisant un moulage interne ça a été
mesuré ça commence a été mesuré parce
qu'il y a un millier de façon de mesurer
avec des marges d'erreur qui varient
donc si on sait pas comment ça a été
mesuré comment on connaît la marge
d'erreur il y a plein de trucs qui vont
pas faudrait savoir
mais ça c'est pareil c'est
cette absence de sève c'est ça qui leur
plaît en fait parce que ça permet de
broder autour s'il y avait s'il y avait
tout le signal devant vous si on savait
exactement de quoi on parlait si on
avait des photos et je rappelle qu'à
chaque fois qu'il y a eu des photos le
gigantisme du squelette était pas gagné
mais si on avait des photos si on avait
ce signal bah il pourrait pas broder
autour il y aurait pas de marge de
manœuvre mais là du coup vu que
l'épreuve ont disparu ou bien vu qu'on a
que des coupures de presse qu'on doit
croire sur parole mais c'est pas du
c'est pas de l'information vérifiée bah
du coup ça laisse une marge de manœuvre
extraordinaire et c'est à eux que ça
bénéficie c'est pas la vérité ça
bénéficie au raconteur ça bénéficie ou
racontar même j'ai envie de dire
de nombreuses publications sont parues
de nombreuses publications pas
scientifiques faut le préciser
et que leur est-il arrivé
ils sont morts
malheureusement même si beaucoup d'entre
eux se trouvaient à la SMI Sonia
ils ont été rapatriés au début des
années 1990
dans le cadre de la loi nakpra qui a
ordonné leur rapatriement des restes des
peuples indigènes américains
ils ont donc hélas tous disparus
des mutes si seulement quelqu'un avait
pensé à les mesurer avant que ça
n'arrive si seulement il y avait eu des
articles publiés sur la taille sur les
dimensions de ces Indiens avant qu'on ne
rapatrie leur corps si seulement oh
merde
ça a été fait oh zut ils étaient pas
plus grand que ça tu vas pas pleurer
j'espère
tu vas pas pleurer hein tu vas pas
pleurer parce que je te contredis ah si
seulement si seulement on en avait
quelque chose à cirer de ce que les
scientifiques ont accompli
avant de raconter nos bêtises
ah dommage dommage dommage dommage
[Musique]
glaner des informations mais seulement
seulement celle qui nous arrange c'est
marrant là parce que ça parle de roue je
sais pas pourquoi alors cette coupure de
presse est très intéressante
ils ont trouvé dans l'une des chambres
sépulcrales de la montagne la tête
d'un
indien qui avait 80 ans
et qui avaient le corps
de 15 pieds de long alors on va refaire
notre conversion s'il vous plaît parce
que
[Musique]
la vache 15 pieds de long ah bah ah là
là on commence à parler là 4 mètres bah
voilà bah voilà levela notre Être Humain
4 mètres c'est dommage qu'il ait 80 ans
quoi 80 ans c'est assez
le seul le seul animal qui fasse 4 qui
puisse faire 4 mètres de long et qui
puisse avoir 80 ans c'est un dauphin
ouais c'est ça donc ça fait à peu près
70 ans total en fonction des espèces
évidemment de 50 à 70 dents au total
donc même les dauphins ils ont pas
autant de dents que ça mais ouais si tu
ramènes à macchabée qui a plus de 32
dents tu vas avoir du mal à appeler ça
un être humain un mec
on va essayer de nous faire croire il
avait il avait 80 ans et vous essayez de
me faire croire que cet article parle
d'un être humain non
c'est pas possible donc non enfin c'est
pour ça qu'il faut de la littérature
scientifique c'est parce que des gens
qui sont capables de voir un squelette
de avec 80 ans et d'appeler ça un être
humain faut non faut pas faut pas les
catacombes de Paris ça parle des
catacombes de Paris
et de comment dans les catacombes de
Paris il y a pas l'ombre d'un géant il
faudra le dire ça
pourrions-nous découvrir encore
aujourd'hui
on va nous parler d'ADN peut-être qu'on
va nous montrer l'Indien en question
peut-être que je vais devoir bouffer ma
page
alors on va nous parler de on veut nous
parler d'ADN on commence l'histoire en
1918 ça va être compliqué
Robert
je vais je vais accélérer parce que
cette histoire elle va m'énerver donc
il était très grand
c'est pas une anomalie il était
pathologique
oui
l'hormone de croissance n'est ni un gène
caché ni spécifique aux humains cette
phrase est une énorme connerie
c'est tout
bla bla bla bla
le domaine très rare environ
0,007% de chaque population présente des
caractéristiques du gigantisme
Robert Wadlow a donc incarné un exemple
vivant de
la sur à l'origine du gigantisme qui ont
été décrits par de nombreuses cultures
différentes
on vient quand même on est quand même
capable de nous dire dans ce
documentaire dans la même dans le même
paragraphe on est capable de nous dire
Robert Wadlow est né de parents normaux
il a hérité des gènes du gigantisme
j'ai rien d'autre à ajouter le
documentaire se débogue que tout seul
il est né de parents normaux il a hérité
du gène de gigantisme
on connaît toute la généalogie de bois
de l'eau
et pourtant on arrive quand même à te
dire il a hérité des gènes du
gigantesque
c'est de l'art à ce niveau-là de la
nullité comme ça c'est de l'art
donc exactement ce qu'il faut pas faire
à grandir à un squelette d'êtres humains
pour en faire un géant
vous vous rappelez 1918 c'est pas bon
pour parler de génétique bah vous voyez
donc le meilleur généticien que vous
avez trouvé c'est un MSI
William Brown MSI donc le meilleur
généticien qu'ils ont réussi à trouver
pour défendre leur théorie PT est un
généticien qui n'a même pas de doctorat
MSI c'est un master
je vous laisse réfléchir là dessus
encore une fois on essaye de trouver des
experts on essaye de s'appuyer c'est le
documentaire qui essaye de s'appuyer sur
des autorités pour l'instant il n'a fait
appel à aucune autorité scientifique
reconnue c'est la première fois que ce
documentaire s'adresse à une autorité
scientifique réelle validé au moins un
par ces proches tu vois parce que le
fait que le prof vous est décerné un
master ça montre que vous êtes au moins
que votre
expertise et au moins reconnue par vos
profs
mais en gros la seule autorité
scientifique qu'ils ont réussi à trouver
jusqu'à présent dans leur documentaire
c'est une autorité scientifique qui a un
master donc qui est un niveau en dessous
du doctorat ce qui n'est pas mal en soi
le problème c'est que les masters n'ont
pas publié et le problème de ne pas
avoir publié c'est pas juste que c'est
un rite de passage ça n'a rien à voir
avec un rythme de passage le problème
c'est que tu n'es si tu n'as jamais
publié tu n'es jamais passé sous le feu
ennemi
tu es un noob la publication elle passe
par un phénomène qui s'appelle par un
processus qui s'appelle le pire
reviewing la revue par les paires et la
revue par les pairs ce sont les autres
experts de ton domaine qui tirent à
balle réel sur ton travail
c'est pour ça que je dis passer sous le
feu et demi c'est littéralement ce qui
se passe si vous n'avez pas fait de
thèse de doctorat vous n'êtes pas passé
dans les tranchées
vous êtes un noob vous êtes un soldat
qui sort de la caserne qui n'a jamais vu
le front
donc votre autorité en tant que guerrier
n'est pas encore prouvé il faut passer
par le feu ennemi il faut passer par le
feu de du pire reviewing pour être
considéré comme un expert reconnu au
moins nationalement si ce n'est
international lui son autorité pour
l'instant n'est reconnu que par les
profs qui lui ont décerné son master
et ça c'est la seule autorité
scientifique compétente qu'on nous
présente depuis tout à l'heure
ça fait déjà un tiers du documentaire un
tiers du documentaire avec eux des
autorités autoproclamées
donc nous avons pu voir certains cas ou
des segments de gènes de l'ADN on vous
montre des animations très compliquées
d'ADN sachant qu'il y a rien de tout ça
qui a été fait jusqu'à présent
qui comportent des segments inactifs
présents
à des humains de très grande taille
oui en même temps on va pas
on va pas on va pas le contredire
puisque c'est arrivé chez Wadlow qu'il y
a un gène qui s'active et qui provoque
une un être humain de très grande taille
mais encore une fois on parle pas d'un
être humain qui a fait 5 mètres on parle
d'un être humain qui a deux mètres 72
été au bout de sa vie
voyez ce que je veux dire on parle d'un
être humain qui a 2 mètres 72 était au
bout de sa vie on parle pas d'un être
humain en bonne santé de 5 mètres de
haut
faut arrêter les conneries faut savoir
de quoi on parle c'est au bout d'un
moment soit on parle d'une race de géant
qui était réellement géante et capable
de faire les empreintes de pieds qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure parce que c'est eux
qui nous les ont montré soit on parle
d'êtres humains pathologiquement géant
mais dans ce cas là ça reste Homo
sapiens c'est Homo sapiens c'est un
point c'est tout
auteur à succès
bon bah voilà
j'allais j'allais dire j'allais dire
justement où j'allais dire ah il est
aussi scientifique
il est aussi scientifique on sait pas de
quoi mais il est aussi scientifique
et il nous dit
à sa connaissance cette preuve ADN n'a
pas été confirmée à l'heure actuelle
12 minutes 5 ils viennent de dire à ma
connaissance un scientifique
proclamé par ce documentaire c'est ce
documentaire qui lui donne 7
crédibilités de scientifiques je n'ai
donc pas besoin d'aller le vérifier je
peux te croire sur parole documentaire
bien sûr donc cette autorité
scientifique
que le documentaire ou que le créateur
de ce documentaire est allé chercher
nous dit on n'a pas trouvé cette preuve
ADN que les géants existaient et c'est
bien normal puisqu'elle n'existe pas à
vous dirais-je et que j'aurais pu te le
dire moi aussi
mais ce qu'il y a d'intéressant c'est
que à aucun moment pour l'instant à
aucun moment on va juste se tourner vers
la réponse évidente qui est se tourner
vers les Amérindiens modernes pour aller
voir dans leurs gènes si oui ou non il y
a du gigantisme enfin du des traces de
génétique de gigantisme je sais pas quoi
ne serait-ce que de se faire des stats
sur leurs dimensions pour voir s'il est
Amérindiens ont une tendance au
gigantisme plus prononcée que chez les
autres populations ce serait quand même
les questions évidentes à se poser elles
sont où ces questions elles sont où ces
questions même même des scientifiques
pas spécialement intéressés par la
question ont publié là dessus c'est cet
article là
pourquoi pourquoi eux ils se la pose pas
alors que c'est ça la réponse alors
qu'elle serait là la réponse à leurs
questions c'est de l'incompétence totale
ou encore une fois ça fait partie du
grand mensonge qui vous raconte
je
et retour au récit retour au récit à
chaque fois c'est il y a des récits il y
a des récits il y a des témoignages mais
oui mais les témoignages ça vaut que
dalle ça ne vaut que dalle un petit
dessin là comme ça ça vaut que dalle va
falloir vous le rentrer dans la tronche
ça le témoignage ne vaut rien ça c'est
la base
la preuve et à chaque fois l'exemple que
j'utilise tout le temps c'est le mec qui
a cru voir un Bigfoot raconté dans le
livre de Brian size du généticien Bryan
six la nature de la bête le généticien
Brian size raconte l'histoire du mec qui
a vu un Bigfoot qui prétend lui avoir
roulé dessus avec sa bagnole sauf que
quand Bryan sax a fait les analyses ADN
du sang du Bigfoot il a vu que c'était
de l'ADN de vache
le témoignage ne vaut rien le mec était
persuadé d'avoir rouler sur un primate
géant de 3 mètres ou sur un indien
d'Amérique poilu de 3 mètres si vous
vous rappelez la petite histoire le
témoignage c'est le niveau zéro de la
preuve ça ne vaut rien je sais que ça
remet immédiatement en crédibilité
remets immédiatement en question la
crédibilité du témoignant et que du coup
c'est quasiment insulter le témoignant
que de dire non mais votre témoignage on
n'en veux pas parce que on peut pas se
fier à ça mais c'est pas une insulte au
témoignant c'est juste factuellement on
ne peut pas se fier aux témoignage et
tout ce qui nous montre jusqu'à présent
c'est on n'a pas de preuve ADN mais on a
des témoignages bon
dans les temps modernes non la question
c'est faux
ça c'est des grands monsieur encore une
fois atteint atteint à l'évidence là
pour le coup c'est assez évident c'est
on a pardon j'enlève le plein écran mais
là regardez la mâchoire
ultra prononcée de ce monsieur qui est
évidemment le plus grand des deux on ne
sait pas quelle taille fait ce monsieur
donc on peut pas dire si c'est si ces
gens sont géants mais regardez la
mâchoire hyper prononcée ça c'est un
trait typique de l'hyper hypophysie
enfin du gigantisme la mâchoire hyper
prononcée c'est un c'est un truc que
vous verrez chez tous les les gens qui
sont atteints ce trouble hypophysaire il
y a différents degrés il y a certains
degrés où vous n'êtes pas trop malade
ceci dit lui il a l'air effectivement
d'utiliser une canne pour se déplacer
lorsque nous examinons le récit de nos
légendes situées les plus anciennes et
les plus précieuses un thème commun en
découle c'est un thème fascinant pour
moi car il démontre que l'humanité est
passé par de multiples répétitions d'un
processus intentionnel pour nous
conduire au point nous en sommes
aujourd'hui ça veut rien dire du tout ce
qui vient de dire la phrase qui vient de
dire ne va rien dire du tout on est
passé plusieurs fois par un processus
intentionnel qui nous a conduit à ce
qu'on a joué de quoi tu parles
juste de quoi tu parles regardez cette
magnifique représentation de l'évolution
humaine où il y a pas la moindre trace
de géant
en d'autres termes de multiples
tentatives
les géants ont existé en vous montrant
en même temps les preuves qu'il
n'existent pas puisque ils sont pas dans
le registre fossile
effectivement eu une recherche de la
bonne forme génétique
de pouvoir de l'esprit humain
alors là on vient de nous sortir le
couplet créationniste donc quand on
analyse la mythologie judéo-chrétienne
on voit qu'il y a eu une recherche
intentionnelle du corps humain parfait
je sais pas moi la dernière fois que
j'ai lu la Genèse Dieu a créé Adam comme
ça
sans tâtons sans tâtonner sans
rechercher sans rien du tout donc je
sais pas donc on est à la fois
créationniste et blasphémateur ce qui
est quand même un record absolu en
matière de balls
là on est sur de la performance
artistique comme le mec dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure avec le reportage
Netflix là qui se tient sur 2000 ans
d'histoire de l'archéologie et leur dit
fuck là on est sur de la performance
artistique
vous voyez il y a il y a PQ la Tour
Eiffel
il y a
grimper le mont Everest en slip et il y
a le mec qui se tient au sommet du mont
Everest en slip et qui clament en plus
vous voyez le livre de la Genèse le
livre de la Genèse et ben moi je suis
créationniste et je vous dis qu'il est
faux
c'est de la performance artistique à ce
niveau-là c'est beau
décès
erreur que Dieu n'a pas commis puisque
Dieu est parfait ne peut pas commettre
d'erreur
n'était tout simplement pas viable c'est
tout au long des siècles parmi ces
formes de vie nous trouvons des
références aux géantes des références
aux éloïnes et on est film qui
apparaissent dans la plupart des anciens
documents de l'Ancien Testament
l'Ancien Testament comme argent comptant
défense défense encore une fois de la
Bible du fondement du bon du bien fondé
des écrits religieux pourquoi parce que
l'histoire de la race des géants est
héritée directement du créationnisme
les créationsnistes ils adorent
l'histoire de la race des géants parce
que c'est fait pour confirmer les récits
bibliques l'histoire de la race des
géants
donc encore une fois on a le mobile
on a le mobile donc on a un crime
[Rires]
c'est des dents de ruminants
le mec il a pris des dents de ruminants
et il les a organisés en arc de cercle
pour essayer de faire croire que c'est
de l'humain
[Rires]
faut vraiment être
ah c'est beau bon entracte aussi
en tractus sciences les dragons parce
que j'en ai déjà parlé en plus de Luigi
machin bidule mais il faut que j'arrive
à retrouver la vidéo c'était là mais en
gros vous n'arriverez pas à lire le nom
c'est marqué dans de Sardaigne en
dessous donc c'est exactement les dents
une de des multiples dents qu'il vous
présente là vous vous admirez d'ailleurs
le flou de la photo pour cacher le fait
que l'anatomie est à l'évidence celle
d'une dent de ruminant donc voici j'ai
réussi quand même aller à la pêche à la
photo nette et donc quand on a une photo
nette de ses dents on voit que les
cusspides ont une morphologie en arc de
cercle en morphologie en croissant de
lune qu'on appelle selenodontes et cette
morphologie dedans c'est les nodonte
elle est unique et absolument typique
des ruminants
et des tilopodes donc des chameaux des
camélidés des chameaux des chameaux et
des camélidés en général
c'est une c'est une morphologie dedans
de grands herbivores qui n'a rien à voir
avec la morphologie dentaire humaine qui
est de type Buno donc c'est ce qui vous
est illustré alors ça c'est un cochon
les cochons sont aussi bu nodentes donc
à la limite si tu veux me faire croire
que tu as trouvé une dentition humaine
est au moins la politesse
d'utiliser une bande cochon parce que au
moins ça ressemble un peu à une dent
humaine parce que ça vous voyez là en
plus j'ai bien j'ai bien illustré là
vous avez la vous avez les deux cuspides
rectilignes qui forment le mur extérieur
de la dent donc le côté coupant pour
attaquer l'herbe et vous avez la cuve
speed selenodontes en orange à
l'intérieur comme sur cette vache qui
sert du coup à mâcher qui est qui crée
un bassin en fait qui permet de mâcher
l'herbe qui est très coriace donc
vous utilisez des mensonges vous
utilisez des gros mensonges pour comme
preuve en guise de preuve ça là organisé
des dents au pif c'est même pas des
incisives regardez il les a organisés en
arc de cercle pour faire des incisives
c'est pas des incisives ça c'est des
prémolaires
il a même pas utilisé des incisives de
ruminants parce que au moins les
incisives de ruminants elles ressemblent
à des pelles donc au moins ça ressemble
à des incisives ça c'est pas des
incisives de ruminants c'est des c'est
des prémolaires
c'est ridicule c'est absolument ridicule
menteur vous êtes des menteurs
parce qu'à niveau d'incompétence comme
ça je refuse encore une fois je refuse
de croire à un niveau d'incompétence
pareil on est sur des menteurs qui
veulent vous mentir pour confirmer que
la Genèse est réelle pour confirmer que
le récit de la Genèse est réel c'est
tout c'est ça qui les motive
voilà ça typiquement dans de regarder
regardez bien cette morphologie regardez
maintenant
cette morphologie là la dent de cheval
ici c'est exactement la même la même
courbure les mêmes
les mêmes traits sur les côtés les mêmes
côtes que vous voyez ici sur les côtés
ça ce sont des dents de grands
herbivores ce sont pas des dents
d'humains
rhésus négatif c'est intéressant car la
Sardaigne est l'un des rares endroits au
monde où l'on trouve aujourd'hui une
forte concentration de ce groupe sanguin
aurait juste négatif ouais tout se passe
comme si le groupe sanguin qui avait
déjà le mec arrive à trouver du sang sur
des dents sèches
je vous invite juste à réfléchir à ça
c'est comme c'est comme les cachets
d'homéopathie vous savez les petits
cachets secs d'homéopathie qui sont
censés fonctionner à la mémoire de l'eau
des cachets secs des cachets secs
d'homéopathie qui fonctionne à la
mémoire de l'eau bah là pareil on a des
dents sèches fossilisées ils ont ils ont
pas honte le monsieur la Luigi il a pas
honte de dire qu'elles sont fossilisées
les dents donc on a des dents
complètement sèches et fossilisés avec
du sang à l'intérieur du sang liquide
pas des globules rouges comme on a pu
trouver dans certains ossements mais des
globules rouges fossilisés quoi non non
non pas des protéines pas du collagène
non non du sang liquide qui a pu être
analysé et comme par hasard
et bah c'est du comme par hasard c'est
c'est du sang de population locale tout
se passant comme si au benido
je m'étais pris un petit peu de sang
pour l'envoyer au laboratoire
c'est ridicule en fait c'est même pas
c'est même pas juste improbable c'est
juste ridicule de s'imaginer que c'est
vrai et vous n'avez même pas besoin de
connaître quoi que ce soit en
archéologie ou en paléontologie c'est du
sang liquide dans une dent fossilisée du
sang liquide dans une dent fossilisée
faut être chez père mais de l'enfer
géants
ce qu'il vient de poser sur la table
c'est une astragale à double
articulation une astragale qui a deux
articulations donc une articulation avec
la jambe et une articulation avec le
pied c'est encore une fois typique des
ruminants c'est une articulation en plus
celle-là elle est bien cubique enfin
elle est bien rectangulaire donc c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment une astragale de
ruminant et rien d'autre pour le coup
encore je vous aurais dit ça peut être
un tragulidé donc ça aurait pu être un
cochon ou ça aurait pu être très guidé
c'est un ruminant mais ça aurait pu être
un cochon ça aurait pu être un
tilopodes donc un chameau ça aurait été
plausible mais là en plus elle est
rectangulaire de fou cet astragale et ça
c'est vraiment typique des ruminants on
trouve ça encore une fois que chez les
ruminants les êtres humains n'ont qu'une
seule articulation elle est entre le
pied et la jambe quand vous bougez le
pied vous n'avez pas besoin d'être fait
un atomiste une fois de plus quand vous
bougez le pied il y a qu'une seule
articulation entre votre pied et votre
et votre jambe les ruminants eux quand
ils bougent le pied il y a une
articulation entre le pied et la
cheville et entre la cheville et la
jambe et c'est pour ça qu'il y a une
astragale à double poulie il y a deux
poulies une à l'avant enfin une en haut
une en bas et là ce qui vient de poser
sur la table c'est une articule c'est
une astragale c'est une cheville de
ruminant et rien d'autre
histoire toujours toujours les textes
aux anciens toujours les témoignages
toujours des images bullshit ils ont
rien d'autre que des textes anciens et
les textes anciens
c'est pas l'épreuve c'est pas une preuve
un texte ancien l'épreuve elles sont là
je vous les ai montrées les preuves
c'est ça c'est les fossiles les preuves
c'est c'est les tous les restes là que
je vous montre là qu'on a retrouvé on
les a les géant ils sont là les géants
et c'est pas des géants c'est juste des
faux cils mal interprétés comme Luigi
bles et je ne cesse d'y revenir parce
qu'ils nous permettent vraiment de
comprendre parce que j'ai que ça je ne
cesse d'y revenir parce que je n'ai que
ça
actuelle et dans la région de l'Afrique
mais qu'elle s'est ensuite déplacé et à
migrer à travers la planète jusqu'
en amène l'un de leurs chefs les a
poussés à migrer en faisant cela ils se
sont mis à s'accoupler avec d'autres
minidés et ont donné naissance à ce
peuple de géant
le livre de la Genèse par le datant ou
les éloïdes les fils de Dieu sont venus
vers les filles des hommes et elles ont
donné naissance à des géants
il a également été rapporté une fois
interprétation littérale de la Genèse
religieux pourrait-il crédibiliser
l'idée que nous pourrions partager de
l'ADN avec cette espèce disparu les
experts suggèrent on sait déjà que non
puisque on les a il l'a dit tout à
l'heure
on s'est déjà que non il y a pas d'ADN
de géants chez nous
il l'a dit
c'est ils sont ils sont vraiment en
train de broder sur du rien parce qu'ils
ont eux-mêmes annoncé qu'il n'avaient
rien encore une expert autoproc
autoproclamée
la Route de la Soie depuis la
Méditerranée jusqu'à la Chine entre les
années 1500 et 1600 ils ont été
stupéfaits de ce qu'ils ont découvert
ils se sont retrouvés face à des géants
de 4 mètres qui servaient de cartes donc
aller impériale c'était d'entre vous
c'était certainement pas une métaphore
pour parler de statut non non non c'est
vrai que Marco Polo il a raconté toute
la vérité rien que la vérité il a vu des
licornes je rappelle Marco Polo entre
autres trucs extraordinaire je suis sûr
que là dans les commentaires vous pouvez
me citer au moins un milliard de choses
de fou que Marco Polo dit avoir vu qu'il
n'existe pas il a pas vu des griffons
aussi Marco Polo en tout cas je suis sûr
qu'il prétend avoir vu des licornes
les années 1500 et 1600 s'il s'agissait
bien des derniers Hanouna qui restaient
là s'il mesurait 4 mètres
soudainement il se transforme en
nanunaki on va avoir les lémuriens
bientôt
concernant la façon de construire des
structures mécaniques ils savaient
comment faire pousser des cultures
les Indiens d'Amérique ça y est c'est
fini on y reviendra plus je pense
on n'a pas eu l'interview d'un indien
d'Amérique ce que pense que pensez-vous
grand chef allez vous faire [ __ ] bande
de racistes
voilà on l'a pas eu on l'aura pas je
pense c'est fini donc c'est bon petit
bouquin tu es sauvé
technologie dont on a évidemment
retrouvé les restes
considéré qu'on a on a des restes
fossilisés de dinosaures qui ont vécu
plus il y a plusieurs dizaines voire
centaines de millions d'années considéré
qu'on a les restes fossiles des animaux
qui ont vécu plusieurs centaines de
millions d'années avant même les
dinosaures
et maintenant considérez la probabilité
qu'on est raté une civilisation
suffisamment avancée pour avoir fait le
tour du monde plusieurs fois
voilà
c'est tout
on arrive à trouver des trucs qui ont
des centaines de millions d'années
on arrive à en trouver beaucoup
suffisamment pour que presque chaque
grande ville du monde possède un musée
avec de la paléontologie dedans on en
trouve beaucoup beaucoup et considérer
maintenant le fait qu'il faudrait que
tous ces musées que tous leurs employés
paléontologues depuis tout le temps que
la paléontologie existe et du passé à
côté d'un truc aussi évident qu'une
civilisation qui est fait plusieurs fois
le tour de la planète et mesurer plus de
3 mètres de haut
voilà et vous avez la probabilité que
cette histoire est né et ce soit
accouplé avec les humains sans avoir
laissé la moindre trace génétique dans
leur ADN
parce que c'est eux qui nous l'ont dit
donc dans leur histoire il faut prendre
ça en compte
voilà
donc on a on a littéralement le c'est
une civilisation courant d'air c'était
les dieux du vent
les dieux du vent je crois qu'il y a pas
un mot de trop là-dedans les dieux du
vent du vent c'est tout ce que c'est
c'est du vent c'est du vent il remue là
il remue les bras pendant ses
explications parce qu'il faut générer du
ventes
je crois que tu peux déjà laisser même
pas obligé de finir la phrase
je crois que suivant
par exemple
oui encore une fois ils n'ont pas le
droit au symbolisme les Égyptiens ils
ont pas le droit au symbolisme mais ils
ont pas le droit à la perspective ça
c'est interdit
j'ai fait caca au pyramide j'ai fait
caca naska j'ai fait caca
les histoires de mon grand-père sur les
brocantes dont je me
souviens alors que nous vivions sur le
Nil des espèces seraient venues du ciel
et aurait peuplé la Terre
les Haïtiens étaient très grands
peut-être deux fois plus grand que nous
et nous les appelions aussi les Annunaki
étaient des géants on a tellement de
preuve de ces bêtes là que on est obligé
de les refaire en images de synthèse
il faut savoir que les navires se sont
répandus dans le monde à l'époque de la
glacière et comment je le sais je viens
de l'inventer
régnaient sur les régions comme l'Europe
la Sibérie une partie du Moyen-Orient et
l'Amérique du Nord il vivait dans la
glace des ressources abondantes qu'il y
a dans la glace vous savez comme de la
glace
ah bah non les humains ils sont pas
suffisamment cons pour se battre pour
régner sur de la glace
sur terre pour transférer les
informations dans la glace vous savez là
où l'information va rester longtemps
c'est vous imaginez une population
extraterrestre qui débarque sur Terre
pour graver les informations à grand
peine dans des blocs de glace qui vont
fondre
mais est-ce que tu t'écoutes quand tu
racontes ça est-ce que tu t'écoutes
certains d'entre eux par groupe de trois
il n'était pas très nombreux dans des
vaisseaux spatiaux
est-ce que tu racontes là c'est Game of
Thrones c'est pas une théorie ça
aucune limite sur Terre on le voit la
ses yeux il cherche là il invente au fur
et à mesure
la seule façon de faire comprendre qu'il
ne fallait pas dépasser un certain point
était par la peur je suis un peu déçu
parce qu'on n'a pas encore entendu à
part à l'introduction que je vous ai
passé du coup on n'a pas entendu la voix
douce de Julie couvreur qui était à peu
près le seul argument pour l'existence
de cette chaîne selon les gens qui la
défendent selon moi c'est des gens qui
défendent la chaîne qui disent je
découvre à la Une jolie voix et c'est
pour ça que je l'aime bien mais du coup
on entend pas savoir du coup qu'est-ce
qui vous plaît là dans ce qu'est ce qui
a plu dans à 200 000 personnes dans ce
documentaire si c'était pas la voix de
Julie couvreur
et d'autres sans laisser aucune trace
unique je le rappelle
il invente vraiment au fur et à mesure
là il y a aucune preuve de ce qu'il dit
là c'est l'histoire qu'on nous a raconté
avant regardez où ça se passe ça se
passe pas du tout en Amérique les seules
preuves qu'on nous a montré pour
l'instant et que dont une ou deux
pouvait encore être considéré comme
tolérable c'était en Amérique du Nord là
il y a rien de tout ça je rappelle en
plus c'est bien je l'ai dit au début
mais le bassin méditerranéen il y a des
il y a des historiens dans le bassin
méditerranéen puis de Milan elle est
passée où cette histoire
c'est c'est
au lieu de laisser votre histoire en
Amérique du Nord là où il y a encore à
une impression de mystère qui pouvait
régner parce que la tradition est restée
orale jusqu'à il y a seulement quelques
centaines d'années vous implantez votre
histoire en Europe enfin en Eurasie là
où l'écriture existe depuis plusieurs
milliers d'années et là où la discipline
historio archéologique existe depuis là
au moins la Grèce antique
pourquoi vous enraciner votre récit à un
endroit où il y a des textes qui disent
clairement que non ça c'est ceci ne
s'est pas produit
et les seuls textes qui disent que ça
s'est produit la Bible vous
raconte ça déjà raconte l'histoire des
géants de façon totalement anecdotique
mais en plus ce qui normalement devrait
pas être le cas ça devrait pas être
anecdotique l'histoire des gens mais en
plus ce contredit elle-même et en plus
n'est qu'un récit mythologique
pourquoi pourquoi enracinez-vous votre
histoire en Europe enfin en Eurasie
alors que c'était à la base en Amérique
du Nord je ne comprends pas
ça n'est même pas logique
ils nous ont tout transmis en tant
qu'humain parce que encore une fois
l'être humain est trop con tu sais
sur cette planète est-il possible je
rappelle que l'agriculture et le feu
sont deux choses qui ont été
domestiquées
à plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'années d'intervalles les traces de feu
les plus anciennes de France voilà
à tout àvel 560 000 ans bon ça se trouve
il y a même des traces de feu qui sont
encore plus anciens plus anciennes mais
en tout cas celle de Tautavel en 560000
ans l'agriculture 10 000 ans
la révolution néolithique de manière
générale c'est c'était il y a 10000 ans
il y a plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'années entre les deux événements ces
deux événements ne sont absolument pas
ne font absolument pas partie du même
assemblage culturel
vous pourriez dire bah oui mais les
néphilis machin mes couilles à nunaki là
ils auraient pu vivre tout ce temps là
et nous apprendre les trucs au
compte-goutte on vous apprend le feu et
puis on va attendre 100000 ans avant de
vous apprendre le reste on verra bien
sachant qu'il y a 500000 ans il y a pas
la glaciation hein donc s'il y a pas la
glaciation il y a pas il y a pas les
Annunaki mais c'est même pas le même
ensemble culturel c'est même pas la même
espèce Tautavel c'est delbergensis alors
que la domestication du alors que la de
la domestication de l'agriculture quoi
c'est alors que l'agriculture de manière
générale la domestication des espèces
qui vont devenir les espèces qu'on va
cultiver
c'est c'est un truc qui est arrivé avec
Homo sapiens ce moderne donc c'est même
pas la même espèce d'êtres humains qui a
appris le feu et qui a qui a appris
l'agriculture donc qu'est-ce que tu
racontes quoi qu'est-ce que tu racontes
non
il y a pas d'ADN de géant vous l'avez
dit
et encore moins chez les Indiens
d'Amérique
et on est reparti en Chine
ça y est
je vous ai dit la généalogie je vous ai
parlé de la généalogie entre les Indiens
d'Amérique et le Bigfoot et là bingo on
va entendre parler du Yéti
il semblerait qu'il ne possède pas de
langage parlé comme nous nous savons pas
qu'il agit
une grosse empreinte de pas qui est
évidemment mille fois trop grosse pour
être celle des géants dont il nous parle
depuis tout à l'heure encore une fois je
veux dire elle est plus grande qu'un
être humain ça c'est définitivement de
l'érosion et rien d'autre
c'est terrible c'est terrible d'être
incohérent au point enfin je veux dire
il nous parle de géant de 3 mètres et il
nous montre une empreinte qui fait 3
mètres
si vous êtes malade vous êtes absolument
malade
bien sûr
on a toujours pas gardé de traces comme
par hasard
non
oui
non ses parents étaient normaux
on trouve des récits encore une fois des
récits des récits des histoires du
blabla
rien de concret
rien du tout il n'existe pas
et les maires de notre civilisation
de nombreux êtres sont venus des étoiles
voilà des êtres venus de l'espace
ils sont égyptiens évidemment ils ne
sont pas blancs et ça date de 1866 on
essaye tout le temps de vous présenter
ces théories comme des théories
nouvelles qui bousculent les conventions
non ce sont de vrais de vieilles
histoires sclérosées jusqu'à l'os qui
n'ont pas bougé d'un iota depuis les
années 1800 et des
théories ne sont pas New Age du tout
elles sont elles ont connu à regain de
jeunesse avec le mouvement new age mais
elles ne sont pas New Age du tout ces
théories ce sont des vrais vieilles
théories coloniales cracra mise au point
pour justifier la domination des blancs
sur les populations américaines noires
asiatiques etc
autant de choses sur nous-mêmes que
parce qu'ils étaient aussi dotés
d'émotions
les autres traîtres comme les arthuriens
ou encore les Syriens n'avaient pas
d'émotions
beaucoup de choses comment tu sais tout
ça mais je le sorti de mon cul bien sûr
nous faisait penser que les dieux et les
déesses étaient comme nous que nous
pouvions devenir comme eux
nous pouvions aussi grandir
ce qui est complètement contradictoire
avec les récits bibliques dont vous vous
servez pour prouver l'histoire des
géants c'est merveilleux d'être aussi
contradictoire avec soi-même
mais quand nous sommes aperçus qu'ils
avaient les mêmes sentiments les mêmes
problèmes que nous nous avons compris
que nous pouvions aussi posséder les
mêmes pouvoirs que nous pouvions devenir
comme eux et c'est grâce à cela que nous
avons gagné la guerre contre eux voilà
comment les humains nous avons gagné la
guerre contre eux mais à quel moment il
y a des questions d'une guerre contre
et c'est ce que nous voulions devenir
nous voulions être comme Poséidon nous
voulions être comme Zeus il représentait
les êtres célèbres de cette époque ah
maintenant ça aussi c'est argent
comptant le vous êtes au courant que la
jeunesse que vous prenez comme argent
comptant est hautement incohérente avec
la mythologie grecque que vous venez de
prendre là maintenant pour argent
comptant vous avez conscience de ça
qu'est-ce que c'est lui c'est le plus
cher de toute l'équipe depuis tout à
l'heure il improvise mais full Blast
nous pouvons tous grandir
donc là c'est intéressant enfin on nous
montre c'est peut-être la photo qui
aurait fallu montrer depuis le début là
vous avez définitivement un être humain
et un squelette gigantesque qui se
tienne l'un à côté de l'autre au même
plan de l'image il y a un léger pdestal
sur le géant mais on est on est enfin je
veux dire c'est pas beaucoup plus épais
que les chaussures que le mec porte donc
là c'est il y aura peut-être fallu
commencer par ça pour essayer de nous
faire croire que les géants existent
pourquoi nous montrer la des coupures de
presse qui nous racontent des histoires
de géants qui sont pas si géants que ça
bon le truc c'est qu'encore une fois on
voit la mâchoire sur développer
typiquement l'un des symptômes du
gigantisme hypophysaire dont on parlait
tout à l'heure donc c'est pas géant
géant en réalité c'est une personne
atteinte de gigantisme et ça se voit
rien qu'à sa mâchoire hypertrophie
pourrions-nous un jour être capable de
libérer la force la sagesse et les
forces
Luc tu dois libérer la force
pourquoi on nous montre un grand trou
pourquoi on nous a parlé de l'Egypte
tout le temps du coup enfin pourquoi
nous a montré l'image de l'Egypte à part
pour dire ils étaient trop con pour
imaginer des géants enfin pour avoir un
symbolisme ou être représenté en grand
c'était
c'était important pour montrer qu'on
avait du pouvoir
prochain épisode vous a plu et que vous
aussi
[Rires]
la race des géants donc de Gaïa en fait
pas de Julie couvreur ce n'était pas un
documentaire joli couvreur et ben j'ai
bien fait de mettre un gros pouce vers
le bas et je suis vraiment très
impressionné qui est quasiment 9000
personnes qui est mis un pouce vers le
haut parce que le documentaire arrive
quand même à se contredire lui-même un
paquet de fois
c'est assez balèze d'en être à ce point
là et ça n'a même pas le charme du coup
de la voix douce et suave de Julie
couvreur donc question qu'est-ce que
200000 personnes sont venues faire sur
cette vidéo je me demande je vous pose
la question et je vous dis à très
bientôt sur notre chaîne Ciao